[Music]
good morning good morning good
morning straight into it man I realized
I got to update the countdown and
everything in case you guys didn't see
your eyes are not to seeing you that is
a brand
new what do we call it man retro re tour
logo I guess right that's that's the
logo now you
guys but man it is uh another cold
morning here for me very very cold
morning we've got snow on the ground it
is
snowing at this
moment uh kids are at of school
thankfully my wife is off work
today and so somebody's able to to be
here with them Yo Dylan what is up my
man Dylan with the five gifted
memberships oh my goodness it's been so
long you guys I know I see all your your
names in the comments on videos but it's
it's a total different vibe right when
we're here live so if you're new if this
is your first time jumping into a live
stream so at the start here I just kind
of do a little just chatting talk with
you guys catch up with with what's going
on with you and then we'll jump into the
game here which I've already got my
how are you I've got my PS3 here right
beside me we got the the Half Blood
prints the hard copy people always ask
like how are you playing these so I'm
well this now we're to the hard copy
versions guys if you got one of those
gifted memberships right there make sure
you thank thank Dylan for that and also
uh you
unlock all of our emotes now so you can
use those here on the channel we have a
lot of Wizarding World themed emotes
which now that we have our clear
Direction here for this channel I mean
we might as well just make them all
Wizarding World themed except maybe the
one of like the hype I know everybody
loves the hype
one all right so who do we got in here
today I see kisi is the very first name
that I see and did we get elen with the
15 months right there
elen 15 months man it's crazy that it's
even been that long since we've been
doing this semi regularly then we took a
big break now we back we back all right
so we got kisi in the house we got Dylan
of course we got
elen Miss
dactyl I don't understand that
reference maybe it's something I missed
we got Christy in the house Christy good
morning which Christie I caught your
your comment last last night did did did
you move
again where did you move if you don't
mind saying I mean if you don't want to
say it's okay I know a lot of
people people weird online you don't
want to put out all your information
there but I don't think I realized that
that you were moving again I knew I
hadn't seen you streaming as much as of
as of late so Arvin good morning Arvin
welcome to the
stream lur d
raafa L
welcome apologies if I mispronounce that
terribly and thank you for the
compliments on the logo man yeah it was
uh there were a bunch
of
Concepts that
I you know worked with a a designer
shout out to from the attic Michael from
the
attic huge supporter of the channel he
and I've been talking a lot behind the
scenes just about branding and that kind
of thing so it's like generated a bunch
of just samples like using AI it's kind
of crazy what AI can do with logos some
of them are just off-the-wall terrible
but then every now and then you'll get
one that's like oh it's almost there so
the one that we
have I tweaked it I took it and just
like made my changes to it and then
Michael took it and made a few more
changes to it and then he he's the one
who did the the channel Banner man the
channel
banner I just I love it so much I love
it so much and uh he had originally done
one that had like a yellow lettering on
it but then once we nailed this down for
the logo we're like okay we got to bring
the logo into there and so I had it
looking decent and then he took it and
just made it look so much better within
like 5 minutes I don't know how he did
it but it was awesome so yes thank you
guys appreciate that and then let's see
we had a bunch of people getting uh the
gifteds right
there so okay we said hello to lore
looks like jarid Amelia
Frosty uh
Danielle Z
Zia that's probably mispronounced as
well my apologies All of You Got A
Gifted uh membership there from Dylan
and then I think Dylan reup his
membership as well I think I saw Dylan's
name pop up DB unknown welcome in no I
did not I did not get through all of
them it was a goal of mine DB to play
through all of them and we made it we
started order the Phoenix that's why so
we just if you guys miss that um we did
just finish up our let's play of order
the Phoenix a few weeks ago so I had I
had made it up to that point but we
didn't make it any
further yeah so since Legacy came out I
I've replayed all of the the Lego games
I replayed both of those but yeah I have
I never played Half Blood Prince as a
kid I don't I don't know why I don't
know if I was just too busy with other
things or read reviews and was like eh
honestly going back now after playing
Order of the Phoenix I can see why I
didn't play it hopefully it's better
don't tell me if it's not do just just
don't tell me don't tell me if it's not
better because man I was so disappointed
in in uh Order of the Phoenix cuz I did
play that one as a kid and had these
clear fond memories of that
game and man is it
rough that game is
rough just like the quest and what you
do it it's a glorified fetch Quest is
really what that is uh Juno welcome in
what do I think of the upcoming quiditch
game well if anyone has participated in
the play
test who knows who has and who hasn't
but if they have participated in the
play test then they can't say anything
about the game I would just say I'm
looking forward to hearing more how
about
that how about that I I am looking
forward to hearing more
yes oh my goodness and we got house in
the house house what's up dude welcome
in good to see you again
house 50k Subs I know dude I know
pressing on press
on let's see what did we hit the other
day we hit we crossed 58 the other day
my goal I mean I I want to hit 100K by
the end of the year I think we can do it
especially if we get if we get any kind
of
big big news this year on Wizarding
World stuff Legacy quiddit
Champions yeah I mean now that we have a
Clear Vision for the channel I mean the
reason a lot of the people people watch
the channel but people don't really
subscribe to a channel unless
they The Branding is very
clear you guys ever noticed that it's
like you find a channel and you like a
video of theirs and then you go and you
look at the rest of their Channel and
you're like oh darn this is not what I
thought this channel was about but now
it should be very clear it should be
very clear so we're doing a second
Channel too that I'll talk more about in
due time but that that that channel will
allow me to do a little more variety
gaming but for right now at least for
the next uh you know three months I'm
I'm committed to this Vision here on the
channel this Vision he's back he's back
indeed Dylan Karen hello from Denmark
welcome in good to see you Karen Arvin
so hyp for this you love okay good
somebody love let's go all right I have
I'm I'm hoping that it's decent then
hoping that it's decent I know there's a
lot of uh there's a lot of potion
brewing in this one so we'll we'll see
how that goes Kaden looking forward to
seeing me play
Half Half Blood Prince me too man cuz I
it's it's such a rare thing for me to be
able to play a Harry Potter game for the
first
time I've barely even watched this one
being played I watched um I know Ben
Snow's done a couple of like
retrospective videos with it I've
watched some of those
but yeah i' I've I just I don't even
know what the gam play is really like in
this one Ryan kingsbery Ryan what is up
dude welcome back Ryan by the way guys
you like the Hat man this is a Christmas
gift I'm loving the Hat loving the Hat
you enjoy the logo as well Ryan thank
you
dude would I be able to do a video on
how to brew all potions is that for you
talking about for legacy or you talking
about for uh for this game
cuz I know this game has a lot of potion
brewing Mrs dactyl that's you what is
this a uh is this the D and D thing that
I've
missed Mrs
dactyl
kisi oh wait every time I see the Alicia
in there it throws me off for a second
I'm like wait has kesi been Alicia this
whole
time you have but
not notah Alicia as we will call
her too funny
man let's see Danelle Danel or Danielle
when are you going to play Lego Harry
Potter we've played Lego Harry Potter so
if you uh you might have to scroll back
I think it was back in
August we don't have like the full Let's
Plays up for for our playthroughs but I
have two you think of them as trophy
hunting videos so it's basically like
highlights of the game but me getting
the platinum trophy so we got the
platinum trophy and the Lego Harry
Potter collection which covers years uh
1 through four is kind of like the first
game and then 5 through seven is the
second game but with the collection they
put it all into one so it's two Platinum
trophies and so we went through and oh
my goodness
no this uh so this webcam that I have I
saw it flash right there it has this
little feature in it where it can like
detect hand gestures and such and so I
think it
ju it just detected my hand gesture CU I
saw it flash yeah there we go we want
the zoomed in
view that's better Mrs retur in the
house as well hey Ben Shore thank you
for subscribing to the
channel I forgot about our old buddy
hagard there you're a wizard wizard hey
there we we go another subscriber to the
channel Derek oliviera welcome Derek
thank you for
subscribing but yeah we got oh dude it
must maybe it like Waits and then
catches up no way we just had back to
back to back Britney welcome in thank
you for subscribing let's see if it has
another
one okay H we're letting hagard rest for
a bit now all right all right Hagrid's
resting hagri is resting a bit now and I
also just saw another member pop in
from I don't know who that is H Julia
for 12 months dude YouTube does this
weird thing like sometimes I see a
different name for you guys so like I
get these little notifications when
there's a comment and if I click on the
notification it'll show one name and
then when I actually click into the
comment it shows another
name it's very
bizarre so I'm guessing H Julia is
someone that I I I know by a different
name yo Anna Pim as well with the
membership Anna welcome in I don't know
why these aren't popping up on uh maybe
it's just catching up here we'll see if
it if it catches
[Music]
up all right let me catch up here in the
comments lure if I don't recogn
recognize your
name that's right I do remember that
comment yes yes yes I do remember that
comment King Tutt welcome
in Derek hoping this would be Chamber of
Secrets we play we have played Chamber
of Secrets we have up our full Let's
Plays of that one at least for the
console version I never played all the
way through the PC version because we
were having trouble getting it to work
on
stream and then we got house with the
Super Chat house what is up dude thank
you so much for the Super Chat so happy
to watch you grow definitely my favorite
content creator
house man thank you so much house always
supporting on the live streams on the on
the videos commenting by the way guys if
you're here hanging out and you're
you're enjoying your time here so far
make sure you hit the Thumbs Up Button
like this video it's going to help more
people find the stream here the music
got really loud all of a
sudden the other thing I'm worried about
with playing this game is that uh it's
got copyrighted music in
there it's got copyrighted
music and then I see um let's see who
was that that just popped up christe yes
of the 15 months yeah I guess membership
alerts are broken all of a sudden now
it's been so long since we streamed
Dylan Dylan broke the membership alerts
when he gifted right there at the
beginning but I do still see them guys I
do still see them so we had a couple
back to back to back there on the
memberships thank you so much guys
good to see so many familiar names
jumping back in King Tut good morning
Stacy welcome in Warrior L Gold Pyramid
no you're not you are not late a wizard
is never late Warrior land you arrive
precisely finish it chat you you know
you know precisely when he means
to no we uh we always do a little just
chatting a bit here on the beginning
before we jump into the
game
Jake welcome in from the
Ukraine have fun with a half BL Prince
game I hope so I hope so I hope I have a
good time with this one and then we got
LW James LW James welcome
dude and then we got let's see Anna in
the chat as well okay so the stuff's
popping up in the chat correctly it's
just not doing the little alerts
correctly uh I I just did see warrior
Lane's question pop up about we are
playing it is the PS3 version of Half
Blood prins that we're getting ready to
fire up here I still have my PlayStation
3 slim and because there's there's like
not a great spot for it on the desk so
it's literally just it's it's right
beside me right beside me
here oh yeah and here's uh there's where
we were playing order the
Phoenix Yahoo good morning it is about
9:15 a.m. 9:15 so we
are we have been going for about 15
minutes here went live at
9 giving everybody time to gather in
here I think for uh like you know how I
love how YouTube just the live stream's
just there immediately you know he can
rewind you can go back and forth and
then when I sign off it's there so
anybody can find
it but I think because of that I I think
I should probably not do the countdown
screens
anymore just jump right
in that way the people that are here you
know early they get a chance to they're
here for the just
chatting cuz they used to do the big
countdown which I think you know maybe
that's better when you do like uh like
our um Hogwarts Legacy streams when we
were just hyping the game and talking
about what's coming no it's not a new
game it is a very old game Stacy yes
Kaden you like the hat thank you dude
yeah I am fond of the Hat as well Anna
says this is your favorite of the old
games okay okay I'm hopeful I'm hopeful
you guys that I will enjoy this one more
than order the
[Music]
Phoenix okay then we had okay then we
had the three subs and then we had those
memberships I don't know why that didn't
pop up for for eight H Julia for Anna
and for chrisy houses thing popped up
the Super Chat so strange Wookie cookie
welcome jumping toad stool Marcos Marcos
said good evening oh my goodness Marcos
where where hold on if it's good evening
for you you'd have to be what like
Australia New Zealand
somewhere and wook yes I never played
those either if we make it through this
one
I think those will be next and those
that's the kind of game I feel like you
have it has to be a stream because
they're so bad like I need you guys to
help me get through
it I need you
guys you're a wizard
Harry okay so Hagrid's working Rudy
thank you so much for subscribing Hagrid
is here it just seems like the
memberships are the one that's broken at
the moment Hagrid I'm glad you're uh
oh that's Walmore H Julius Walmore let's
go I knew that had to be a name I
recognized because it's it's a one year
member come
on so excited for the Half Blood Prince
playthrough Jamie said you love this one
okay all right you guys are getting me
sufficiently
hyped uh
Jaden great to see your life man much
love yes alive and well we are live and
well just took a bit of a a break from
from streaming for a
while live not gotcha dude gotcha wook
still remember uh record scratch when
Jenny says she's going to Hogs me with
Dean oh
man waldemore with a super chat
waldemore thank you so much for the
Super Chat really appreciate it man
waldemore always showing love always
showing love Dylan say maybe more gifts
we'll fix
it oh goodness no it was like uh it
worked for the gifteds didn't it but
then after that it was done actually you
know
what hold on I'm going to fix this and
then we're going to we're going to jump
into the stream or to the to the stream
to the
game you saying that actually made me
realize it worked for the gifted but
then when you and L win both I I don't
think it I don't think it popped up for
either of those okay so let's go to our
overlays this is on the full
cam alerts oh my goodness it's going to
do double Now isn't it
toind who was that Kaden
wait oh no how are you did we did we
break it further now all right so let's
see I'm going to mute this cuz I'm
looking at my preview right now that's
why you guys heard it double kayen
thanks so much for becoming a channel
member right there appreciate it man
guys thank you so much for the support
all right let me click this right
here variation
settings yeah it's it's set to show up
all right well it's not what I thought
it was
so all right let me just save
that yeah stream elements man just
having to it's dusty there it it's been
a while they're like what this guy's
streaming again this guy's
streaming we don't need we don't need to
make sure his alerts are working n no
[Music]
no you have the physical version of this
one Anna wook you have the PC version
what a throwback you love your PS3 Slim
I know dude I feel like the
last he was probably the last good
slim because the the the original PS4
was already so stink and slim welcome to
Griffin all well we we got the little
popup in the alert now it's just not
showing the
names it's just not showing the names
welcome to
griffindor looks like Jaden Mrs R oh
hold on eln gifting out Dylan gifted one
and then we have elwin gifting out five
members ships let's go looks like Mrs
raking tour got one Jaden got one and
then we had Let's see we got we had
Cadence Cadence membership
Rael Silva jumping toad stool and house
all getting memberships right there eln
and Dylan thank you so much guys
appreciate your support guys if you're
uh so when you're a member you also get
access to we do a lot of these
um like Channel update videos that are
members on only videos and so we've done
I don't know probably six seven maybe
it's more than that it's more than that
I try to do one a month how are you so
you should now have access to all those
if you go back you can you can watch all
of those you also get access to members
only polls so sometimes I'll PLL the
members the members actually got to look
at the logo before we officially decided
we had a couple Concepts going so I got
feedback from the members so we do do
some of those from time to time in
addition to the the channel member the
uh the emotes that you guys see
here wake up early
house 6:15 for you elen oh my gosh it's
so early 2:17 p.m. for toad in the UK
gotcha Yeah Anna I did make sure to uh
to get it up
before kind of like a full well not a
full day not a full 24 hours but but no
no I want to try to make it a regular
weekly thing again I'd originally
planned to go live this week on
Tuesday but my kids had a snow day my
wife was working and they had to do like
school from home basically instead of
getting a fullon snow day so I'm glad I
never announced it because yeah I had to
back out of that but usually this time
works pretty well for me like during the
week because the kids are at school but
I'll probably do it it would probably be
on Tuesday so we can call it triways or
Tuesday Wario you like the no don't tell
me that I I did not enjoy Order of the
Phoenix did not enjoy
it all right oh my gosh we're we're so
far behind all right here we go rapid
fire catching up on chat rapid rapid
rapid fire Marcos 4M in Greece
gotcha Warrior land you're in Europe and
it's 5:18 p.m. Dam dang your dog is
scratching at your door to go and let
jumping toad stool my dog does that all
the time regulars of the stream you guys
know she always wants in and out like
right now she she's just right beside me
she's right beside me but if she ever
goes out then give it five minutes and
she's going to want back
in Australia's probably already asleep
by now deep asleep no
way thank you Dylan yes if you guys are
uh having a good time
make sure you hit that like button smash
that like button I see the little hearts
popping up so that must mean people are
liking the video thank you
guys stay humble how's it going
everything to do with Harry Potter makes
you feel like a curious kid again right
it just has that it has that way about
it zeko yes indeed you made it to a live
stream loving the Hogwarts Legacy music
in the background yeah I thought it
thought it would help set the Vibes and
they're usually pretty good about
not giving you the c o p y r i g HT
sometimes I think when you say the word
I think I already said it on this stream
it like wakes up the little the little
bot that checks for
it cuz like every time I mention
it it always gets hit like as soon as
the live stream ends sometimes when I
don't mention it nothing for a while
all right now we're I'm just catching up
to when Ln gifted out lwin and Dylan
gifted make sure I don't miss any of
their comments zeko my day is going well
so far I started my day with you guys
started it with you Jared you're loving
the look of the new logo thank you Jared
appreciate it it was it was a tough
change for me I'll be honest I love my
logo I still love my logo my I I can't
say my logo anymore because it's you
know but it it it just might be my logo
on a different
channel in due time in due time it's not
dead it is not
dead you still have your old PC disc for
this one Wario
nice yeah I know that's why I I still
have like even some of the hard copies
of uh like if you have like Chamber of
Secrets dude that game runs so
incredibly well on the Dolphin Emulator
the console version I know you're
talking about the PC versions but
SCA or scatha welcome in Frosty gigabyte
welcome to the stream gab welcome Andrew
thank you so much for subscribing
welcome in a21 edits first time on live
stream just for a bit hey all good dude
all good just appreciate you stopping by
and saying hello Martin 11:30 a.m. for
you we got gab in
Brazil you're a wizard
Harry currently buried under a foot of
snow King Tut dude we got a lot too well
a lot for
us Anna you're right I do need to update
the badges whenever Dylan commented last
night and I saw his badge right beside
him I was like oh dang it we've got to
update
those we got to update those wait was
that house gifting out three
memberships did I miss house gifting
three membership oh no that was house
getting dude guys I don't even know
what's going on with the alert before
before right now I don't even know
what's going going on with
them I don't I don't know what's going
on with the the alerts if I miss you I
am so sorry I I appreciate you guys so
much thank you so much for the
memberships for the likes for the gifted
memberships what did I saw Warrior's
comment what didn't I like about the uh
haet PR D or order of the venix it was
just like it was fetch Quest it was it
was a giant fetch Quest that's all you
did it's like Hogwarts they did such a
good job with with like the school and
the students and everything but the
missions like the actual gameplay the
wands the
combat I held my hand up one time during
during the uh one of the Let's Plays and
like my I'm fighting Voldemort and it's
just
like give you a little ASMR
there that's what it
was just just over and over it's like
what is this man after Hogwarts legacies
combat
jeez I was like what is that I don't
have an alert set for that that would be
the
copy RI ght Half Blood Prince is more
the same oh my gosh don't tell me that
Professor Drew don't tell me
that don't tell me shh see it's like
awesome see it's like it's like Legacy
before we had Legacy all right guys I
think that's a good transition Point
Let's dive in I think it is time to dive
in thank you all so much for being here
and hanging
out it is now time I'm gonna have to
update all the uh like the like like I
don't have a transition anymore so now
it's just it's just
this we're just we're just
there all right so I'm actually going to
mute the game audio for a second
here so I think let's see if I mute this
I should still be able to hear
it tell me if you guys hear the music
right there I don't want to let too much
of it
play I'm going to do it again tell me if
you hear the music right there
I don't think you all should be hearing
it you feel like half Prince is much
shorter Professor Dre see that's what I
need that's what I need Professor Drew
nothing okay good all right
so I just want to get to the point where
it's not playing blasting hedwig's
theme
that's like one of the songs you know
where it it it just takes if it hears
like two notes of that
song the YouTube c o p y r i g HT
detection is like oh
copyright and I just said it dang it
it's like the band
word oh man even when you're trying not
to say it you say
it
sheesh I wish they just had an option to
uh like a lot of more modern games they
give you the option to turn it
off all right I don't think we it's not
playing it right now so wait hold on it
might be part of the intro
sequence all right turning off the
Hogwarts
music oh yeah it's playing it hold
on oh this is kind of
cool here I'll just I'll just do the
music for you
guys all right hold
on okay wait it's done never mind I was
looking forward to that I was really
looking forward to that all right I
think we're good
now
giving us a little preview here of
what's to
[Applause]
[Music]
come I do know there's
quidditch is that a little bit too loud
for you
guys it's loud in my ear
but yeah Mrs rur we're going back in
time for
this it's pretty cool
intro bit loud okay I was thinking it
was loud for me
so all right let's take that down a
bit no stop sh sheesh what's with these
game like barely giving you any time to
[Music]
uh all
right Autos save feature very
[Music]
nice well here we
go Cherry Coke
Zero # not sponsored
the Dark Lord knows I serve him that
better then swear to it to make the
unbreakable
vow will you SE snap swear to watch over
Draco will you swear that if Draco fails
you will carry out the Dark Lord's
orders I
will
I do love the animation of like the the
daily
profit oh
no is this disc scratched up or is that
just supposed to cut between
scenes oh I guess that's what I was
supposed to
do hey it's the
burrow bloody hell wonder if the game's
going to burn it down like the movie did
probably so hey harry hi Jenny Harry
you've been chosen your Gryffindor quits
Captain I knew you'd get it you not
flown all summer though so you'd better
get some practice come on Mr chosen one
you can use my room
thanks she said Mr chosen
one all
right come on man oh wait it's inverted
hold on hold
on uh invert flight controls
off subtitles let's turn those
on where is it and spell list I like the
menu a lot better
already I got to convince myself this
one's better just humor me you guys just
humor me the room in
this
you won't catch the snitch if you don't
aim at it am I not aiming at it
Jenny
bril that's great
Harry CL
done go
[Music]
on I love that they just immediately
start you with
this well
done I think we're closing in on
it oh I hit
something
[Applause]
whoa right through the
[Music]
hoop you love the flying in this game
it's pretty uh like it's easy to control
that's for
sure
things stay on it tril didn't know what
that sound was for a
second you're almost there by the way
guys this game has
trophies hence our thumbnail for today's
live
stream it is still so loud for me should
be low enough for you guys but I'm
turning it down more in my ear
heyy there we go speaking of
trophies dude I need to move my cam got
be able to see the trophies as they pop
in got to
be might have to visit these after
Hogwarts is complete you mean Hogwarts
Legacy you still working on Hogwarts
Legacy
Adam hey Christian gamer welcome in ruie
welcome I'll see you
later
[Music]
oh honestly what all you need to do is
clean them out you could have done it
already if you hav had a helping dinner
starving all right well they definitely
it it definitely feels like Order of the
Phoenix even if the C the camera might
be slightly different did you get here
about half an hour ago didn't run tell
you I would have but you've not let me
get a word in if you'd done these jobs
for your mom I wouldn't have need needed
to speak to you mom wants us to get rid
of these cauldrons Fred and George had
left in the garage I'll give you a
hand that one smells far worse than the
others yeah
[Music]
definitely
you did cost that quite well great let's
get rid of the rest of
them press L1 or R1 to change targets
okay move them in the
air oh my goodness there's their old
uh
laundry washing machine out there we
guard
wonder if we're going to be washing
clothes with Mr Weasley in
this you guys have never played the Lego
games man you are missing
out you actually get to have a little
moment with Mr Weasley while doing the
laundry M would have made us oh my
goodness the trophies still being
scrubbing them at Christmas already
another one take time to some cleaning
spells he wants to spend their time
cleaning things up this was much more
fun you guys didn't know I'd love me
some trophies Undead Joe
welcome it's so Dum it's kind of funny
right
[Music]
right why is Draco sneaking around I
don't know but that needs to bargain and
Bs that's a little much like he's just
walking with his
mom
it's an initiation
ceremony why would you know who make
that idiot Death Eater why else would
Malfoy be in borging and burgs I'm going
to find out and if I use the
invisibility CL he'll never know I was
listening in will
he
you go on I want to check something oh
dude I remember reading this part
Palace sneaking about listening in were
you
[Music]
Potter yep I knew I'd seen someone climb
up there well enjoy the trip back to
London
poter
Potter
oh hello Harry what are you doing down
there what were you doing down on the
floor I was trying to find out what Malo
is up to I'm sure he's a Death Eater I
was wearing my invisibility cloak but he
must have seen me when I climbed onto
the luggage rack maybe he saw your Rx my
what rxperts was he wearing Spectra
specs you can see rxs through them
that's how I found you your brain's full
of them right let's get to the castle
we're probably already in trouble for
being late okay although I'm worried
about tripping over things in the dark
maybe we should use
[Music]
lumos follow Luna to the
castle
can't do any can't do wingardium right
now right now
[Music]
okay what's that how exciting Zeno
welcome and we've only you own this game
and played it let's pick it
up it's pretty cheap actually this one's
one of the I mean not expensive but it's
kind of
a I wonder if there are any more of them
bit surprising how much this one still
costs at least for PS3 it was a bit
harder to
find I think it was like 20 25 bucks or
something they're pretty easy to find
used it's just for some reason this one
uh costs a bit
[Music]
more another Crest I got another one oh
well done so there's 150 of those which
I assume we will need all of them for
the platinum
trophy you have just unlocked two player
dueling pack Draco and
Luna and speaking of
trophies um Wario you were saying you
can control the camera what am I missing
is it a
different oh wait if you hold R2 no way
then you can spin the camera
around you guys are who have never
played this are like what why is he
making a big deal about that you
couldn't do that actually in order of
the
Phoenix PS3 game man I mean we're not
it's not like we're talking the original
Nintendo or something
here so frustrating that you couldn't
control the camera in that game release
mini crests by moving R forward
twice I'm pretty sure I saw some hidden
back behind us collect mini crests by
running over them
oh and then we have to fill up enough of
these to make okay I got it I got
it all right Luna uh can we go back
here because it looks like those yeah
see see
see Trophy Hunters you guys know I mean
how aware you have to be for all these
little
Collectibles is the dueling a lot better
in this one nice bronwin welcome into
the stream good to see you
you've been wanting to play this game
got sick on New Year's Eve
no but you oh you're going to go for the
Platinum too nice collecting Shields
will unlock more Arenas and characters
for the two-player dueling mode PC
version does not have two player dueling
therefore rewards are much less valuable
[Music]
interesting all right it doesn't look
like it's filling up much at all I don't
know if it's supposed to give us a
little visual indication or not
[Music]
but all right let's make sure we didn't
miss any of
these so see that little faint kind of
Halo that was around them is gone now
that's our
indicator what to look
for no yeah they're not uh kisi it's
they're not available digitally they may
be available digitally on PC Wario could
probably actually no he Warrior was
talking about the disc but yeah this one
um I had to get the hard copy for PS3
silver Legion welcome
in I have heard good things yeah about
the the potion making in this
[Music]
game
all
[Music]
right no not the
pumpkins oh look at that you got a
little visual label right there should
we go up to the castle that's for people
like me you guys for people who
are no I think even I would recogniz I
Haggard's Hut but I that's kind of
cool all right let's see can we do
anything with this
Leos
launched come on nothing we don't get
anything for
[Music]
that yeah I think I think you're right
Wario I think it's just the Lego games
that are
available let's go to the castle hold
Luna just just
Crest collecting okay working on that
platinum trophy are you looking
for you know going back and playing
these older games for those of you who
have watched us play a lot of them you
know I always like to joke about the
characters kind of urging you on when
you're trying to
explore and I used I was thinking like
oh wait wait wait that that just gave us
the uh a large Crest
there I like to joke about the older
games doing it but when I was playing
Spider-Man it actually had a moment
where it it forced me into a mission I
couldn't believe
it I think it was something that like
had to be done for the story some of you
may have been in that live stream and
remember
that but I had I never seen a game do it
quite like that like I was just it I was
in free roam and it kept popping up and
telling me like hey you need to do this
you need to do this I'm like just calm
down wait a
second and the game's like no sorry
you're you're doing it now we need you
to do this right now all right so I
don't know if we can get that Crest on
top of the Hut
yet what is
this looks like a spot for incendio once
we learn
[Music]
it potterhead welcome
in it's all
good
a wizard is never
late professor Drew missing the gameplay
from prisoner
basan yeah I mean I feel like that was
the
last really good Potter game
right until you know not counting the
Lego games and Legacy of
[Music]
course cuz I've I've played um goblet
that's not a good game
I've played order and while I can see
why people like it I still think
prisoner is
better and then you have this one which
I can't really speak to yet as I haven't
played it all the way through all right
I know she wants me to go up to the
castle just kind of looking through here
to make sure there's not any other
obvious mini
crests so uh a21 I played the console
version
of prisoner but I've heard Wario being
one of the people particularly with
chamber that the PC version of chamber
very well might be the best Potter game
and I started playing it we did this
gosh this was months ago year year or
two ago probably that we were trying to
live stream
it we and uh I just kept having trouble
getting it to because it's such an old
game you know your PC you basically have
to trick your PC into play it but um it
was messing with my streaming software
so I couldn't like position things so I
just stopped playing it but what little
I did play of that one I can definitely
see why people love the PC version of of
[Music]
chamber and Wario I did see your comment
earlier about um
some sort of special oh there it is
there it is yeah the extended mod comes
with brand new engine which windows can
handle dude I might have to uh DM you
about that at some
point Christian gamer considering doing
the PC version of the first three so I
did um I have the let's play up of the
philosopher stone PC version I did that
one that one is uh you can watch that on
the channel actually I've never played
the uh I never played the console
versions of philosopher
stone which I own them and I'm pretty
sure that the oh dude I could play so
the original PS1 version we could
actually get PS1 Hagrid man on screen
the PS3 the PS3 can play PS1
games even though it couldn't play PS2
games at least most of the most PS3s
can't but there's one that could but
most of them
cannot um so I have that game we could
do that at some point too that'd be
fun now you talk about going back in
time with the graphics going to the PS
one version of sorcerer
Stone would have so
many so many uh odd moments I'm sure the
oh I can't go any further no give me
those crests
[Music]
they remind you of the beans
right yeah mine can't play the PS2 games
either
lore as you know each day dark Forces
are attempting to penetrate this castle
for this reason I have agreed that the
duing club will
restart now please join me welcoming
horest slug horn who will resume his own
position of potions Master meanwhile the
position of defense against the dark
arts teacher will be assumed
by Professor Snape no how can D all he's
done
it was like that in order of the Phoenix
to I am up to no
good new area
unlocked okay this is kind of cool well
there's one good thing the defense
against the dark arts jobs jinxed snap
will be gone by the end of the year and
personally I'm keeping my fingers
crossed for another death I would have
thought you would be at potions Mr
Potter or is it your Longo your ambition
to become an aura I was told I had to
get an outstanding in my owl and so you
did when Professor snap was teaching the
subject but Professor slug horn is
perfectly happy to accept students with
exceeds expectations at Owl however
brilliant I'll head there straight
away but I want to do potions I'm dead
awful at
potions I don't know how to get there
with half the castle locked by the auras
I'd ask near any head to Nick he can
still get around so he knows all the
shortcuts
whenever you need help press select to
summon nearly headless n all right let's
just do it I just want to see how it
works py hell and how are we this new
turn all fired up and ready to win the
Quidditch cup for gryffin to again I
hope yeah but right now I need to get to
potions do you know our way around this
security noise but of course just follow
me and be a pleasure to help
out at Le potions isn't with SN this
year I wonder what slug's like how are
you
KY with the five gifted memberships kisi
thank you so much for gifting out those
memberships you guys looks like
Christian gamer scaa to ruy Nathan dude
Nathan in here hanging out what is up
Nathan and then Shadow teal all just got
a gifted membership right there Ki thank
you so much for the
support that means that means so much
and guys if you got one of those gifteds
make sure you thank
kisi and uh also enjoy your emotes man
get access to all the
emotes we got like double nearly we got
double near nearly headless Nick in the
game and nearly headless Nick are in the
alert right here welcoming us to
Gryffindor literally as we are here
exploring the Gryffindor common room all
right there's got to be a way I can get
this Crest down right how are you
pressing select will always summon Nick
to guide you to your main quest however
you can also select where is oh yeah I
was wondering what that was that right
there when you can select that how are
you welcome to
Gryffindor brightness okay here we
go all right so it goes up to five
that's a little
like that's too much but that's that's
where we're at right now I think three
let's try three for a bit
all right so we've got four out of 125
so you need 25 of the small
ones wait three out of 25 and then three
what's the 300
for silver Legion the face animations
were not the
best yeah cuz I mean these games they
they were always under a big time crunch
right because they were trying to get
them out for the
movies which they the first couple of
games they had they had a little bit
morean Leos Liberty in
that all right let's see how in the old
games that would be like an
AO 25 okay so you need 25 of the small
ones to equal one big one mac and cheese
welcome in thank you by the way 300 mini
Crest total needed to be 100% okay
gotcha gotcha
H probably just don't have what I need
yet what Mysterious Ticking Noise Wario
says
throw no way I bet we could have done
that at hagrids
too for the one on top of his
[Music]
Hut Crest collector to let's
go thank you Kaden yes just need to to
knock them off PS1 version of sorcerer
Stone was pretty
intense yeah what's so interesting about
that one is it was uh part of it was
similar to what they did in PC but then
other parts were just completely
different man look at how far we've come
with like the common rooms and such ooh
there's another one right
there oh hello
crest
they really did do a good job with the
castle though in these old
games all right so anything else we can
do in
here doesn't look like it for
now can't go into that side all right so
hold on let's
see that one right in front of
us can we hit it I bet we
can can I wingardium from up here I'm
not looking at chat for a second don't
tell me don't tell me don't tell
me and let's go there we
go Nick's like come on
dude you summoned me and now you're not
you're not ready to go what is
this what is
this you just focus on the game and then
went back to get
them yeah I'm just kind of trying to do
it so the trophies will be I won't have
as many trophies in the end all right
what's the little thing flying around
that it doesn't look like a snitch
but I wonder if I need to do anything
with
that I really must pay
violent
collecting the Min Shields see I wonder
if once I learn AO can I use it on those
too I'm guessing no since they just told
me like hey you need to uh throw the
[Music]
objects this game was the first HP game
to have a platinum trophy I was thinking
that was correct bronwin I didn't know
for
sure
but here we all
Harry thanks Nick we gryffin TOS must
stick together anytime you're stuck and
need directions advice information just
call out and I'll help if I
can appreciate it
Nick with all the ghosts Griffin to get
Nick he couldn't even get his head cut
off properly
he got us here didn't he that's what I'm
saying Harry come on Ron why you got to
do our boy Nick like
that but yeah brn that's what I was
thinking because Order of the Phoenix
was one of the last PS3 games to not
require trophies if you guys didn't know
if you were uh any of you who are a bit
younger in our audience or who didn't
just didn't have a
PS3 that era is when they first started
doing trophies and at first it was it
was an optional
thing but after a time they started
requiring it for all games so order the
Phoenix did come out on PS3 but no
trophies man very
sad very sad that it didn't have any
trophies all right so hi Harry hello
there nice to see nice to see you hi har
hey hello sir okay grand staircase
shortcut let me see if there's any more
obvious spots
for our little mini
crests all right I think we got them all
on the
Torches first potions lesson I was
beginning to worry sorry we're late sir
and I'm afraid Ron and I haven't got
books yet not to worry you can get what
you need from over there
all right I know a lot of people uh
there's a lot of potion making in this
game e into the year I think open up
your books and let's get busy with a
witch sharpening potion shall
we um witch sharpening potion we made it
in our fourth year just do what I
do all right highlight any bottle and
press to
select AR Zillow
bile press X to let go okay select the
shape of the select the bottle of the
same shape and color as
this press X to let
go select the bottle of the same shape
and color as this as this one
here
great select this box bottle then pour
until the potion turns this color oh no
we actually have to let's add some of
this we actually have to
uh all right how do we pour how do we
pour probably the right stick I'm
guessing oh my
goodness waiting for the
yellow wait is it going oh I'm not
pouring it
in oh there we go there we go
we got
yellow all right select this one let's
add some of this now until it turns
purple
whoa dude okay I I can see why people
like
this I love that there's actually some
uh mistakes will cause smoke like this I
was thinking like if I held it too long
or if I didn't hold it long enough wait
what press L2 then R2
repeatedly being quick and careful fills
your time bar whoa whoa whoa whoa what
did I do
wrong to try again select the book and
press
X to continue select the C yeah I think
we're I think we're still good right I
feel like that's a good
potion is he going to grade me on it now
there are definitely days I could do
with some of this
oh jeez we're on a timer okay hold up
hold up hold up all right we need it to
go
green there we go there we go all right
now we need this one here until it turns
red I do not like I do not like that I'm
on a timer I'm panicking I do not like
it all right then we've got this one
here until it turns yellow
there we go then we got you again until
we're
green all right you until we're
[Music]
purple did we get
it potions beginners luck badge bad Miss
Granger hurry well done my boy
well now we have our juices flowing let
us turn to the cure for dude that was
that was fun what's this not going lie
oh Harry it's a firste potion have you
forgotten all your
rision once they add in the stirring
heat oh we got to heat the potion now
wait what up down up down up
down keep going okay all right all right
[Music]
oh you have to heat it until it changes
color
okay oh man it's like fighting uh it's
fighting Voldemort all over again up
down up down up down up down heat the
potion until it turns this
color not
yet there it
is Ryan De La Cruz Ryan welcome
in good to see you
Ryan you had to shake the Wii
controls it's like the Wii there are
some things that it was probably much
better and then other things I did play
the Wii version of when I originally
played Order of the Phoenix it was the
Wii version I saw you asking earlier
about
that but I yeah I just wasn't a big fan
of the all the the
waggling by the way Christian gamer did
I miss your did your membership not pop
up if I missed that Christian gamer my
apologies and then scatha and ruy I
think those were gifteds though if I
missed that sorry about that guys thank
you so much welcome in all right to try
again why would I need to try again we
got a right didn't we I guess it's just
if you want more
practice a hot little potion this one at
at least it is in the making of it but
be careful not to let things get to Hot
care a hole in your cauldron can be
expensive and
painful oh great here we go okay wait I
guess that's heat it wants heat how do I
heat I don't have to I was thinking I
had to aim at a specific spot but I
guess not no I want you red you've got
to turn red you've got to turn
red okay now you're red you're red
you're red now I just heat you until
you're
green we're definitely running out of
time on this one all right there we go
there we go there we go now we l
one no no no no why is it not letting me
pick
[Music]
it oh dude we are not yeah already at 30
seconds we got to speed it up
man oh wait did it just give me more
time when I completed that section oh it
does okay all right that makes it a
little more
manageable there we go we got blue we
got blue snake fangs luckily powdered
and no longer attached to the snake is
that
it oh that was
quick I think we might him do we mess up
on that
one now this one until it turns
red there we go someone's written a note
on this wait what red is for beginners
heat until the potion goes pink that's
just a student notes it can't be the
proper way to make it or they would have
printed it in the book yeah but well I'm
going to try these
notes ni
with the 17
months Nico what is up dude thank you so
much for the
membership there we go right there right
there right
there I'm not sure why it didn't pop up
on screen Nico stream elements is like
having an off day not bad at all my my
my Harry pink uh yes I must have no no
no red is of course the basic potion but
pink excellent you have the makings of a
master potion maker you should be ready
for something a little more complicated
then yes let us try the draft of living
death I told you to make you go pink sir
you haven't told us what's in that
little golden bottle ah what you see
here is Felix felicis more commonly
known as liquid luck one sip at you will
find all your endeavors succeed and this
I offer today to the student who Bru an
acceptable draft of living death a small
vial of liquid luck so gather your
ingredients but keep your eyes on the
clock good luck an I I bet it doesn't
thank you my instructions are perfectly
adequate suit yourself I feel like games
have only in the past I don't
know okay that right here in the past
last I don't know decade or so been
getting better about
that
you kind of like a teal yeah all right
heat it heat it heat it heat it heat it
till it's
purple right there boom stop stop stop
stop
stop okay this one over
here okay this is actually pretty fun oh
no oh no no no no no no no I shouldn't
have been talking about it being
fun okay yeah I I I'm going to get a bad
grade aren't I I'm so sorry slug horn
I'm so sorry
dude sloth bra oh is it is this one till
it turns blue and our timer is I kind of
just want to
restart there we go all right heat heat
heat we're running out of time you guys
till it turns orange right there boom
boom boom
till it turns
green back to this one come on the
controls I'm blaming the controls
yes all right heat it up heat it up heat
it up heat it up heat it up that looks
good warm wood ooh the black one is it
that
what I was trying to say before I messed
up is this is actually fun I like that
there's a a challenge no no no I did it
again please leave us a little air in
the room Harry prepare to present your
potion all right I'm not going to talk
about whether or not I'm enjoying this
you guys whether I think it's a cool
gameplay mechanic because apparently
every time I do
I can't
focus so we're going to lock it
in we're going to lock it in we're going
to watch oh that I I think I did
something really good there did you hear
that little
something that little ding ding ding
yeah I'm pretty sure that's what it was
you
guys it was like best potion maker of
all time right there you are good at
this aren't
you it's like if you can match the color
perfectly I bet they reward you even
more all right is that the
brain oh no I think it's this
one oh do you hear it do you hear it do
you hear it
yeah orange okay
[Music]
stop till it turns green right
there all right now we want a nice blue
like
that heat it up till it's kind of a pink
right there the black one oh look at all
our
time wonderful
wonderful glad that doesn't
spill oo just a little bit of that
one stop stop stop stop
and Stargazer Tim as well with the 16
months it's clear you've inherited your
mother's Talent she was a daband at
potions but this here as promised one
bottle of liquid luck use it
well use it
well all right now maybe I can talk
about it that that was fun I I like that
mechanic honestly I didn't think I was
going to whenever because I I had seen
it in screenshots and stuff before but I
was like eh people always talk about how
cool it was I like that they really made
it its own like there's a there's a
challenge to it and it really does
obviously fit very well with this book
and
movie but Nico with the 17 months again
not sure why it isn't actually popping
up on screen Nico thank you so much dude
Professor sharp would be proud indeed
indeed and then we had Stargazer Tim
right behind him with the 16 months it's
been a minute let's see swick and FSH no
no no no that's not it don't tell me
it'll come Swish and flick yes indeed
you got it Tim you got it the liquid
luck part of the game is going to be fun
later on oh
dude that was such a funny part in the
movie right like I didn't love Half
Blood prints as a movie but they
definitely
nailed that whole scene like the liquid
luck
thing that was done very well all right
nice got another Crest there let's
see dude's like why are you sneaking up
on me like that Harry just over here
trying to brew my
potion all right any other spots where
we can find a mini
crest
I don't think
so can we not go in
there what is that is that his private
room his private
study can we go in any of these little
side
rooms I don't think
[Music]
so nah looks like you
can't
the love oh they actually have that part
no way so this is where all right the
way it's set up in hogwart's Legacy if
this is where you come
in their office is right there so it's
kind of a slightly different BL you me
doing her Mining and revising all summer
no it's the textbook I borrowed it's got
notes all over it I just followed their
instructions huh you don't need a potion
to be lucky I mean I could have picked
that book but no I get the one that
looks like it's been puked
on Harry Potter look he's not talking
about the prophecy he's not talking
about the daily prophet and he won't
give you his autograph so clear off pip
sque no you've been invited to join the
Gryffindor Julian Club in the Great Hall
oh right thanks sorry it's okay oh
professor mcgonagal said to tell you
there's a short cut to the Great Hall
behind that the password is libraries
liberate Ching Club you should be
brilliant at that all the da members
should let's go and see if any of them
are
joining if you wanted a copy of this
game would you have to try GameStop
maybe I don't even know if GameStop
sells PS3 games anymore I got mine off
of uh eBay is where I found my
copy but yeah like um I don't know where
depending on where you
live there's uh half pric books actually
sells a lot of old
games might find some luck at like a
Goodwill or something
too yeah half pric books usually has a
pretty solid selection of games whenever
I go hi
hurry I know dude Ron's like a he's like
a bodyguard or something in this game
it's like Harry's personal
bodyguard like liberate you speak the
password so may pass oh his voice is
[Music]
different the other one he's like you
may pass Mr
Potter portrait novice unlocked all
right dude I'm loving the the pace at
which these trophies are popping right
now of course this was like one of the
first few games with trophy so this is
back when they were just like eh give
him a trophy for completing this give
him a trophy for making it to that point
in the game which most games still do
that a little bit
but then you also have the trophies
where you have to do these random
off-the-wall
things I don't think this one's too
crazy you just have to collect
everything yeah there's a store in my
area also called uh Game
[Music]
Exchange you would probably like my
video about
uh I have a video on the channel about
going and buying all of the old Harry
Potter
games you guys haven't seen that
one it's a it was a fun little
[Music]
Adventure all right where were we even
supposed to go I don't remember where I
think they said great hall
right for the dueling
Club it's
long oh right you locked the great hle
is it excuse me just a
moment we could have just knocked you
could open the door could
you oh thank you that's awfully good of
you thanks Nick not at all anything I
can do just give me a yell anything
anything at
all whenever you need help oh yeah we we
know that thank you drew I'm glad you
enjoyed it man I had so much funus
Matlock is in charge let's ask him what
we need to do Angus Matlock who the heck
is
that that's got to be
a a character made up for the games
right no way I forgot a
dude in Harry Potter named Angus
Matlock yeah gab I'm looking forward to
hearing more about it like I would say
I'm like cautiously optimistic right now
I want to I want to wait and you know
they they definitely have to prove
they've said it's going to be a faithful
adaptation but you got to prove that to
us right like you got to back that
up which since the big announcement we
really haven't heard heard
much since
then all right let's see what the
dueling's like in this game let's see if
they improved
it we got a message asking if we wanted
to join the jny welcome in good morning
we you Harry Dumbledore's restarted the
jeweling club and we don't want
Slytherin to beat us what do I need to
do could you do a demonstration Jewel
for us to help teach others getting
woken up be fighting you know who just
another Gryffindor okay can we start
correct way of saying that but cast
stupy R ready on the count of three
demonstrate the spell Stupify 1 2 3
cast all right it is to attack cast
Stupify like this all right so it's just
up up
dupy oh no wait it's just you just have
to press at one
time okay wow it's an honor to watch you
cast Harry you're brilliant okay now you
first years watch this Harry's going to
show us the most basic defense dodging
Ron you cast Harry you dodge his
spells okay Dodge jinxes by pressing oh
okay that's
new nice one har they didn't have that
in the other games
I don't know why I can't just now apart
from dodging there's oi you pay
attention listen up we're going to move
on to expell armus this belt is really
useful if you want to finish a jeel
quickly Harry could you demonstrate it
for
us uh use expell arms to disable your
opponent like this expell
arm so that I can see how they're trying
to get rid
of the excess wack
that was present in order of the Phoenix
you need
toly or your
OPP just like go crazy with it then
brilliant Harry ready for a proper Jewel
okay Ron now you can fight back there
will be three rounds May the best
jewelist win come on it's weird that R2
L2 are Dodge ladies and gentlemen of I'm
glad they actually put a do today
competing for a chance to join the
Gryffindor jeweling Club on the left we
have Ronald
Weasley Ronald Weasley come on Ron on
the right the LA the boy who fought he
who must not be named is he the chosen
one the boy the legend Harry
Potter all right I'm going to I'm going
to let him make the first move actually
no I'm going to start straight off with
a Stupify we're Stupify right off the
Jump
Stupify
ex got you
Ron oh can you just
keep run back back
up why are you getting so close to me
Ron like dude
what why is he this is a duel Ron he's
like trying to get up here and punch
me and yes as you guys point out why is
he throwing the killing
[Applause]
curse run why does he keep why does he
run at you like
[Applause]
this oh come
[Music]
[Applause]
on I don't like that he wants to get so
close
super ex how come I can't do that he
fired off like four spells in Rapid
[Music]
succession
[Applause]
[Music]
no do I have that much more Health than
he does that kind of wasn't fair was
it no okay there we go I think he's down
to his last hit point if that's what
that little glowing orb
is okay so you can fire them a little
bit
faster all
right just keep spamming superi yeah
yeah yeah that was just that was just a
first round all right let's see if we
can
just
run
dude why would you want to get so close
to somebody in a
duel training for the ballet
[Applause]
Potter oh that's kind of crazy when you
when you fire them off quickly like that
they're not as accurate
[Applause]
come
on there we
go
[Applause]
nice
spell arm is then spam
Stupify okay let's try
it Dodge spell
armas I don't even know if I need to
dodge like can I literally
just
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah oh you actually will work if you
hit him while he down oh wait what is
we're being graded on this good and
great longest chain Health
[Music]
bonus that's kind of cool that there's
actually a score to it I wish I knew
like how to
do what specifically they were looking
for
but dueling beginner we have a winner
Harry Potter oh man she was not happy
I'm proud to welcome you to the
griffindor jeweling club come back and
prce with us she just turned her back on
Ron like you can sign up for Geor on the
notice
for go and meet Ron outside and what
apologize to him he's not going to be
happy all right so he said the notice
board if you want to duel again you go
to the notice board
here dueling Club
Gryffindor oh this is kind of cool
Junior duel so you have to do I see to
progress to the next
one all
right
Lum oh wait is lumos an automatic thing
because I didn't press
anything oh wait was Ron back here he
was back here wasn't
he
Luna oh my
goodness she wants
out a true Gryffindor not shooting M's
down Dumbledore asked me to give this to
you how did you get in such a mess we've
been jeweling well honestly it would
only take you two seconds to straighten
up afterwards Dumbledore says he likes
acid pops huh it's the password
Dumbledore is going to give me private
lessons this year he'll probably want to
teach you some really Advanced offensive
magic because of the prophecy come on
Ron I'll help you with that defense
against the dark arts homework uh yeah
right all right I had to turn my heater
on hopefully it's not too
uh hopefully it doesn't give too much
background noise but it is getting cold
and colder and colder in here go to
Dumbledore's office for your first
lesson oh that's
cool
that is cool that we're going to get to
[Music]
uh oh yeah it's all good Martin no
worries no
worries just try to keep the chat
relatively familyfriendly every every
now and
then a little one here and there not a
big
deal all right so yeah because I'm
trying to think about all the lessons
with so we didn't get the scene at slug
Horn's house in the game which is in the
Lego
game all right so if we need to go to
Dumbledore's office no we just missed
like all those didn't
we all right Nick where you at hey Nick
well now Harry off to see dumbledor we I
think he's in his office though he has
been away from the school rather a lot
recently drew that that's usually
exactly what happens and especially when
I'm streaming and obviously got the PC
going at the same
time like playing a game on a console
and streaming it usually warms up in
here nicely but I think it's just so
cold right now
outside so wait you can have different
interactions at night
apparently cuz I'm pretty sure we
already
whoa that one had a
lot okay the crests are
gone Nick what here we are at your
chosen destination glad I could be off
wait this is where Dumbledore's office
is uh acid
pops good evening Harry you got my
message I see what what you see before
you are memories in this case pertaining
to one individual Voldemort this
contains the memory of the day I first
met him I believe you're familiar with
my pensive this time you enter the
pensive with me and even more unusually
pronounce it here and we shall see Tom
Riddle as he was before he became Lord
Voldemort I had gone to offer him his
place at
HS
how do you do
Tom you can do things can't you Tom
things the other children
Can't You Can Do
Magic say
what is there anything in that box you
ought not to
have he stole from the other children
and
works we can learn much about Lord
Voldemort from his past a past that
brought him to Hogwarts and a teacher he
grew close to I'll take that slug horn
yes Harry Professor slug horn likes the
company of the famous the successful and
the powerful he collects them and you'd
like him to collect me yes har getting
close to Professor slug horn will be
useful now that is all for tonight I
shall tell you more
soon I solemnly swear that I am up to no
good man I feel like the game's moving
moving
fast hey you losers from the Gryffindor
loser team
of losers that's imaginative did you
think of that or did Maloy let's see if
you're laughing when your team trials go
wrong you
losers I heard a rumor slythering we're
going to try and sabotage our team
selection we better get to the quiddit
pitch before they do anything the auras
have reopened all the grounds let's go
through the clock tower that should be
the quickest way there come
on
I'm sure it is but if anybody watches
this uh on the VOD if you guys are
seeing this and the audio sounds strange
or weird at any point it's probably
because I have uh fortunately YouTube
does give you this feature where to keep
the video monetized I can like remove
the audio after the fact it's kind of
crazy crazy how this works but you can
still hear me and it'll just take out
the music in the background so if I
sound a little robotic or anything
that's what's going on but if you're
hearing the music right now then
congratulations because it
is very wonderful music to listen and
relax
to that's where Dumbledore's office was
that year thanks
to Rena ravenclaw's Ever Changing floor
plan
what do you mean by that like uh
ravenclaw's Ever Changing floor plan is
that an actual is that an actual lore
thing that I've forgotten
about there's the clock tower all right
let's grab a few more of these she just
wanted out and she wanted back
in all right I think we got
that JG what's up dud dude welcome only
2° in Kansas my goodness man yeah like
across the US the past week has been uh
incredibly
cold all right so we've got to knock
that off hey Crest collector
4 let's go dude got to knock that off
[Music]
somehow
H I bet we have to get that Bell to
ring and then it knocks it
off she's like dude you know you got to
get to quidditch
right I'm like yeah but the crest the
crest Luna is actually a
cat oh she is very
uh not like not territorial in the sense
that she doesn't like it's not like she
cares if you in are in her space or
whatever
but she wants to be able to go where she
wants to go freely in the
house and so when the office door is
shut she doesn't like
it all right so there's a bench over
here no way we have to launch that one
right
so all the gears are turning is there
anything we can pick up
here for Wingardium
Leviosa man maybe that's something else
that we're going to have to get
later very hot in
Australia man it's been so cold for us
right
now
Christian which OG Potter game is the
best my favorite is still probably
chamber I think the console version of
chamber all right he's looking that way
is he like trying to give me a hint
about how to solve
this okay we've got kind of a good angle
on it right here if I could pick any of
this
up I can't I can't use wingardium levosa
on any of
this row physics actually kind of
impressive right doesn't look too
bad I'm almost positive we need to get
that Bell to
ring all right maybe I'm making it too
complicated let's try this let's go back
up here and just look right at the Bell
and see if we can do that on the
Bell what if I just look right
here
Noe the hidden ending in chamber if you
die Tom R comes back
what that that almost seems seems like
something worth making a video on like I
need to go and try to actually get
footage of
that
dude why can we
not I don't think it's walking over
there anybody know anybody know on this
one any
guesses
man I'm
confused just a
name welcome
welcome um what's the realistic like
that we will ever see these games being
remade be happy at least caring over the
original
music like seeing the versions as they
are just
like cuz there's always that like you
have to clarify remaster or remake like
I don't think we would ever see these
games remastered where they like just
upres
them and maybe refine the controls a bit
and call it a day I think it would have
to be a full-on remake like completely
new devs obviously cuz these Dev teams
are long uh they have long since changed
I'm
sure but I could definitely see them
remaking doing brand new versions of the
Harry Potter 1 through 7 see the thing
is though like it's like seven that that
is a that's a big commitment but if
you're going to do it I mean I would I
feel like when the TV show comes out
would be like that would be a great
time plus if he had Avalanche software
working on on it let's see I'd I'd
rather them make hogw py too but maybe
if they had a second
team like use this use the castle that
they built they already have the
castle all right
guys can do the pulso yeah I don't have
a a chair or something to throw at on a
lower level okay yeah I was looking
around for like I thought maybe you
could throw these barrels or some of
these boxes here
like these benches it's not letting me
pick these
up and somebody was asking about which
uh so my favorite version of chamber was
the console version that's just the one
I
played but I have also heard very good
things about the PC version as being uh
one of people's favorites all right I'm
going to I'm going to look down here if
we don't find anything never mind we're
just going on to Quidditch
just going on to quiddit are you going
to quiddit this afternoon yes I don't
want to talk about it Saint
Potter
what have the Aus decided to close this
again oh dear how you going to get to
your Gryffindor trials you shut this
yeah see you losers how are we going to
get to quiddit
now
I think you'll have to fix the lever
raparo should do the trick
raparo
raparo great that will show [__] and the
others when guardian levosa oh that's
interesting Dylan only non ding
spells
guardium uh incendio and repair well
done on raising the port colors if you
need a shortcut then come through here
do you offer a shortcut to the quiddit
pitch not exactly just to the grand
staircase but I may come in handy later
great thanks if you need to use my
shortcut again just say dashing Kagan
come on dash go to the qu
trials all right I'm kind of ready for
some quidditch here
as soon as we grab these though Katie
you know we got to grab the oh my
goodness there's so many oh wait and now
you were saying we should be able
to
[Music]
yes hey
you yeah yeah they're they're outdated
for
sure that's why I'm saying I feel like
it would to tell the stories again it
would have to be like completely made
from the ground
up but if it was Avalanche software
or a team from
Avalanche or if they like you know lend
their tools to another Studio within
WB then they would already have the
castle which is like a huge part of
it yes now we can fix the broken Crest
that's
awesome I know i' that's at least I
remember one other one
somewhere oh did we miss those we
[Music]
did all right I think we got
them all right let's do the full-on
Gears of War Sprint here Harry let's
go oh I ran into that guy
sorry can't you guys see we're trying to
get to quidditch out of the
way how did you get through that pork
Cullis poter you were a bit stupid let's
see you run your stupid Gryffindor TR
when you've been stupified
get to the pitch and make sure they
didn't attack anyone
else
that he goes to as
caban I forgot to point that out because
they say await he's awaiting trial at
asan
[Music]
right or maybe do they even say asan or
do they just say awaiting
trial wait I see something back
there I know for sure they say awaiting
trial I just can't remember if they say
at askaban or somewhere
else all right Which Way Katie which way
we going in
this this is the
[Music]
allery is the Quidditch pitch this way
too
[Music]
yeah drew that they definitely like I
feel like that's the biggest thing for
the next
sequel they have they have to make more
choices actually
matter because I didn't want to fight I
didn't want to fight the uncle and and
see I feel like they could have very
easily that would have been such an easy
thing to do is if you don't want to side
with
Sebastian just switch that fight where
you team up with his uncle to fight him
instead it can still end exactly the
same way in fact it may have even been
better to have him like do the AK on his
uncle when you're like if you were like
working with
him but yeah just overall I and I think
they know that I think enough people
have
talked about that and honestly I think
they probably wanted to have it matter
more okay wait what were we supposed to
do with this was it literally just to
get that Crest
or I should have read paid more
attention yeah Ellen from what I've
heard balers Gate 3 is like kind of set
the standard for uh choices and
branching narratives
which is one of the biggest reasons I
want to play it even though I don't
think I will like the
combat but I just I just want to see
like I've heard people say that you you
can get a completely
different game basically by how you
change up the choices you make which is
like what we were hoping with Hogwarts
you
know oh man look at all
please come on why is it not
working no Drew I never I never
[Music]
have oh wow first try let's go dude
where are we even at right
now what what this little passage this
is how you get to the the Quidditch
pitch
going through a random
cave grand staircase shortcut no
way HP4 you talking about Goble of fire
yeah Goble of fire was uh definitely a
disappointing game some of the
decision say think you could introduce
me to your friend Granger wouldn't mind
uh getting to know her on a first name
basis know what I mean oh no come on
Harry we better go in and get
started uh right thanks for coming this
morning I'll be putting everyone through
a series of challenges to select
gryffindor's Quidditch team but know
this how's it going just because you
made the team last year does not
guarantee you a spot this year oh yeah
does that include you too don't be dense
he's the captain doesn't mean he's still
a good Seeker does it maybe he got
injured fighting all those Death Eaters
before summer maybe he's lost his Edge
go on Harry show them how it's done
jinny ain't having good enough show I'll
make mclen eat his BR jinny ain't having
it don't think I've forgotten about that
Crest though please don't put me
straight in the air darn it there was
that Crest right in the center of the
room now we've missed
it it's all right I'm sure we'll have a
chance all right here we go first time
playing some
Quidditch
Chaser whoa whoa whoa what are these
dudes I don't know if we're supposed to
hit those or Dodge
them I'm going with Dodge right now she
said barge
them is that a British
thing barge them what is that that
[Music]
[Applause]
mean what does barge them mean you
guys if she wants me to be flying into
them of course you're supposed to hit
them no
way back up
dude why are you blocking me like
[Music]
this now that one they were down below
me I think those are the ones I oh we
still got it nice barge means smash into
them well we managed to dodge every one
of
them hey we still got a trophy though
let's go Precision flyer
badge combo flyer badge okay that's
three each back to back trophies it
comes down to this last shot I'll take
it
what the heck dude with that Miss mclen
St at just three okay Ron you're go make
it a good
[Music]
one yeah that's a new uh I did not know
that phrasing and qu without last
Captain that's a silver trophy brilliant
Ron you did brilliantly
Ron first game is against Slytherin be
ready when's the first practice just
look at the notice board the practice
sessions are on
there did you see mlagan that last
attempt was so bad you'd think he'd been
confounded well he uh Hey Hing have you
ever heard of the spell sectum seor no
oh my isn't from that potions book is it
yeah and I found some writing at the
back it says the book is the property of
the Half Blood Prince I've never heard
of him you should turn that book in
don't be mental it's
brilliant
H meet Jenny outside of the Quidditch
gate all right but first Jenny but first
but first but
first
we've got to get this Crest it's just
it's just staring at me right there you
know quidditch notice board Gryffindor
triy outs isn't that what we just
did I
thought yeah yeah that famous tickling
charm
oh okay apparently that one you can just
wingardium right on over to you and
Quest dude why do I keep wanting to say
Quest collect Crest collector 5 and this
actually has me curious let's see how
many uh dude the PS3 menu Blast from the
Past right how do you even look at
trophies on this I've completely
forgotten how are you hey potterhead
Mando no Martin with the tin gifted yo
Martin dude thank you so much man the 10
gifted memberships right there guys 10
of you just got a gifted membership from
Martin look for your name popping up
there in the chat look for your name
popping up here above me right now
Martin thank you so much for the support
dude it mean it means a lot man it
really does I appreciate you
guys so whenever you have a membership
here on YouTube guys that means you get
access to all of our emotes you also get
members only polls members only videos
that I post from time to time usually
try to do one a
month how are you welcome to Griffin
dude where
is the
trophies I'm drawing a blank how are you
welcome to Griffin seriously Martin too
kind man too
kind all right so hold
on
no that just brings that up welcome to
griffindor yeah I just saw potterhead
Mando's name pop up first but yeah it
looks like potterhead Mando Kaye Skyfall
King of the North I'm Jay-Z rip
badwolf um Murphy aan your friendly
neighborhood Italian what a great name
and then uh shaie I hope I'm pronouncing
that
correctly with the gifted as well
congrats guys make sure you think Martin
there G Martin gifted you on expect a
ghost stream last night hey that's
awesome
Ryan that's
awesome there we go okay wait it's under
PlayStation Network I knew we'd find it
eventually PlayStation Network and then
trophy collection oh dude remember it
had used to have to do this
sinking Teresa welcome in
and I said it right let's
go let's go I forgot all about this man
that you used to have to sink your
trophies to
gind oh man that's too
funny and it's only at 30 it's it's like
not fast either to you have to wait a
bit all right I turned the heater on and
it's still not I'm going to have to
crank it up a bit more oh have it about
halfway right
now actually now's probably a good time
to do it while we got this
going and guys if you are uh hanging out
and enjoy the stream and you haven't
already hit the like button make sure
you do that hit the thumbs
up that is going to help more people
find find the stream and anybody who's
watching in the VOD later on if you're
watching this after the fact I always
like to I've been doing this lately in
some of our members only videos put an
emoji we need to come up with an emoji
you guys what emoji do we want themind
to comment if they're if they've made it
to this point in the VOD we want them to
leave a comment with let's do hey I just
saw the lion pop up on the screen let's
do the lion Emoji the lion
Emoji post that in the comments below
let me know you made it this far into
the live stream all right here we go so
here's what we got in terms of the
trophies here's what we're looking
at Grime Buster we've already got that
one clean up after Fred and George at
the burrow done use the pensive that was
a cut scene done quidditch Captain done
then we got great party create a great
Christmas party for slug horn that one's
probably going to be automatic then
we've got a hidden trophy which I think
back on
PS3 I don't think there was a way to
force and show now you can show the
hidden trophies help the student
retriever gob Stone help run avoid
lavender hide the half BL Prince potions
book I'm guessing a lot of these are
going to be Story related use your first
portrait shortcut use all the portrait
shortcuts Adventure complete okay and
then we have how many of these Crest
collectors because we've gotten five so
far six seven eight oh my goodness
there's 14 Crest
collectors then we got the potions
beginner badge earn the Speedy Brewer
badge okay that's got to be something
related to doing the potions quickly
earn the potions Club star badge potions
Club veteran badge Master potion near
The Reflex badge dueling Champion Master
duelist Keen
fly yeah see they don't tell you how to
earn them here man they have made so
many improvements with the trophies is
anobi and I know right with the
gobstones
that's too
funny all right so not I don't think
it's going to be too crazy difficult for
the platinum and I've heard that things
aren't
uh they're not really missable except
for
the you just have to go and gather all
of the items that you missed all right
so charms yeah there you go Dylan was
right just have three non-c combat
spells and so dueling right now just
have Stupify and expell armas but we are
also going to unlock Prego petrificus
totalis Lev Corpus and then charging
what
what remember when we thought the PS3
was fast I know right my PS3 is the uh
the slim model the slim PS3 is the one I
have all right and the game does
autosave right I think it said autosave
yeah do you think Dean seas in her jinny
I don't know she's got nice skin nice
skin man's got nice skin hey harry uh I
need to uh yeah me
too could you get me some sweets from
honey Jes I've got to write two essays
and make a shrinking s of homework sure
J so I can't go I'll make the shrinking
solution for you then you can come to
hogsma since when of you into potions
it's no problem slug horns let some
students set up a potions Club in the
herbology green houses I can make it
there okay thanks I'll meet you back
here
later all right potion time I solemnly
swear that I am up to no
good I haven't even looked at the map
yet
managed go to thology Greenhouse like
can you even pull up the map can you
pull up a map in this game
where is
maybe Boat
House well hello there oh and then Nick
just Tas you
there just do current
[Music]
objective that's weird that you can't
pull up the map at
all just to even look at
it oh I bet we need incendio don't
we oh no
nice oh for that one we need that one we
need
incendio oh dude this music though
really nice nice Chill
Vibes as we roam the Hogwarts
grounds
come on there we
go there we
go zenobius great great granddaughter
[Music]
right I'm thinking there's is this a
puzzle or
something it's so weird that you
couldn't jump in these games
too oh that's something right there
little mini
[Music]
ones got another Crest over here I knew
it was going to do that come on it won't
let me go through right
there yeah Arvin that's
true
all right I see I see what I'm going to
[Music]
need this right here
maybe oh I wonder if we can use it on on
that nah just incendio
huh all right can I get you all the way
over there probably not right it's
probably too far
so is there anything in the area here
that we can use it's like that one that
was just sitting on the table it's like
oh sure you can use Wingardium Leviosa
on
this but the these that are up on the
wall no no no no you can't do it oh
maybe this right here yeah there we
go all right all right so that is 32 out
of
[Music]
150 nice
boulder perfectly placed Boulder okay so
what's the point of this dung bomb being
here
then if not for
[Music]
that it definitely feels like an
incendio one but then why would they
have this
[Music]
here maybe we missed the other time
no all
right you definitely want to run it's a
long trip oh does it take a bit to get
over
[Music]
there I'm kind of just taking my time
exploring the grounds here making sure I
gather all of these
items oh of course oh yeah that one
absolutely wingardium
[Music]
perfect okay I see something over
here man it might get kind of tedious
hopefully you don't have to find every
single mini crest for the for the
platinum
trophy like all the big crests
sure but all the mini ones dude that'd
be
crazy
what are you guys doing press X to talk
to I told you this is my skying snack
box do I look like I care just give it
to me or I'll Jinx you a face full of WS
why don't you get your daddy to buy you
out of your lessons instead hey why
don't you leave him
alone oh and the pleasant music at the
same
time
I definitely feel like it's more
accurate if you kind of pace your
shots oh is that Pego he's got going
over
there oh he got me with expell armor no
way it gives you an excess of mini ones
okay that's good to know Christian gamer
I was hoping that was the
[Music]
case
yeah he's definitely blocking a little
bit
more oh I'm getting kind of
low all right all right all right all
right all right all right
nice ha you're the loser see you
Harry you're the
loser a lot of smack talk in this game
huh 35 I mean we've we've only been
playing about 2 hours making good
progress I'm pleased with
this I'm definitely pleased with it all
right I think we uh we might have lost
Nick though while we were doing that oh
man that one's blocked by the spider
web lift and throw objects okay wait is
there something else in the area then
[Music]
yep oh great we're going to have to back
up for this one aren't
we come on come on
Harry let's just sit it down over
here
wait it it almost looks like it's
supposed to
sit
oh man I was trying a
reparo it looks like it's supposed to
sit on top right
there from
downtown Harry Potter makes the
shot 36 out of
150 all right so that one's blocked by
the gate right
here but there's got to be a way to open
open the
gate open the
gate wiggle that wall I know right
waggle waggle waggle hey Warrior it's
all good dude no worries man I know you
guys got got stuff do places to be
anytime you guys can pop in even if it's
just for a minute just to say hello it
means a
lot all right so I wonder if we have the
ability to open that gate now
so the last gate that we had to open we
needed
the the little handle okay that's
herbology which I think is where we're
supposed to be
going all right I'm just going to wait
on that
one wait weren't we supposed to go to
herbology or were we supposed to go to I
need to find the potions Club I think
you'll find that particular little
gathering in the her apology green
houses I'm here Nick I'm
here oh nice Wario nice sounds
good hold the shoulder button to
strafe wait no way potterhead hold
on okay wait so I you use
this wait it's still
floating oh that is
crazy that's a good tip though that
might come in handy when we're trying to
knock some of those crests Off the
Wall dude I don't know why this this
game it feels way more alive than Order
of the Phoenix
[Music]
did like finding all these little crests
anything over
here locked I'll have to find another
way
okay I was wondering that Wario I wasn't
going to actually I may have said it out
loud when we got closer
but yeah I was kind of confused by that
wait can I now just walk over
there okay how
about Oh Come Harry there you go dude
there you
go Crest collector
six okay that must mean there's another
I was going to say there's got to be
another Crest all right so with that tip
we can now hold
L2 no way yeah that's big thank
you hi is this potions Club yes have you
come to join I've heard you're brilliant
at potions this year thanks but I just
want to make a shrinking solution I've
got to get back to meet someone sorry if
you want to use our you'll have to join
the potions Club all you need to do is
choose the entry Challenge on the notice
board over the there okay thanks entry
Challenge on the notice board is see
like all the things with the notice
board all these little extra activities
it feels much more alive than Order of
the Phoenix all right so it's right over
here if you can beat the record score
for Brewing volubilis potion you can
join the potions Club hey have a good
one Professor Drew valous potion is one
of my favorites some people just use it
to play Tri on others to change their
voices which seems a waste of a good
potion to me I'm thinking there's one
that must be related to doing something
really fast because that name of that
trophy okay heat it until it turns red
or green
now come on come on come
on oh my
goodness there we
go oh wait why is it not
why is it
not what watch out what was
that oh we yeah let's just let's just
let it expire well it's an interesting
color why why did it not let me move on
is one of my favorites some people just
use it to on others to change their
which seems a waste of a good potion to
me all right let's heat it till it's
red there we
go again again again again waggle waggle
waggle
again okay right there nice all right
now
we
no okay heat it till it's
red now we need this
[Music]
one heat it until it's
blue right
there this one
again I don't know why I'm talking out
loud every time but it
Mandrake quieter than the life
verion a little
more syrup of
[Music]
helor heat till it's
red nope Noe no no no no more more more
right there all right now till it's this
kind of goldish yellow like
that come on trophy trophy
trophy dang it I'm going to have to look
up and see what that one what you have
to do for that one it say something
about
speed potions Club member badge wow you
are good no one else has brewed bous
potion that well before you can
definitely join the potion Club thanks
can I make my shrinking solution now I'm
in a bit of a
hurry lift this bottle stewed lacewing
flies shake the bottle oh no they're
introducing a new
mechanic until it bubbles like
this over shaking makes the potion Fizz
up like this wait until it bubbles again
before using it
press X to continue pour the bubbly
potion into The Cauldron until it turns
this
color dude the controller kind of
vibrates too let try
again nah
continue the
shaking uh-oh everybody's saying the
shaking is
tricky keep going until you hear the
ding r
then get right to the next instruction
okay all right we're going to have to
shake it
up no
[Music]
okay crab should take some of
this oh great here we
go wait where is it this this thing
right
here
oh we need five of them
one
two
three
four
five yeah controller kind of
[Music]
vibrates oh wait do we have to shake it
first I think we
do okay it's
bubbling oops
[Music]
no oh no what did I do wrong watch
out
practi plan is for have another
[Music]
gu perhaps should take some of this hey
you're heading out Christian thanks for
being here
[Music]
dude okay
one no I
[Music]
missed Morty snow days with
retro what is up Morty welcome
in okay it's
bubbling nice okay I guess I just
didn't shake it long enough last
time heat till we're
purple oh four of the
rats no not
you
[Music]
what is that
thing oh these over
[Music]
here I'm missing on some of these trying
to see if I can speed things up a
bit all right back to the purple one
shake it
up get the Fizz
[Music]
going right there one of these
guys this is
[Music]
crazy all right heat it up and we're
done that wasn't bad that wasn't
[Music]
bad oh yeah the cam does kind of block
the UI on that you're
right but moving it moving it up higher
wouldn't be I mean maybe if it move it
to the other side see how you doing the
other challenges come back and try them
great I'll definitely have a go but I've
got to meet jinny Weasley at the
Quidditch pitch now that's okay just
come back
anytime take the shrinking solution to
Jenny at the quiddit pitch all right so
we can kind of look around here for a
bit then
[Music]
right yes another
Crest yeah we might try top
[Music]
left oh no I wonder if I I may need to
hurry since he has the
potion probably doesn't matter but ni
are you there I have to get this potion
back to JY we I heard Missy I have seen
games before that it's
like not now crab I'm going to meet
someone looks like you're going to be
late doesn't it
stupy
stup
whoa what was that spell
crab
[Music]
there we
go he just got stuck for a minute in
that one
spot
come on expell arm is just it it doesn't
fire it off as quickly as
[Applause]
Stupify come on one more there we
go yeah dueling's definitely an
now you know what it feels like to be
bullied that was great Harry crab and
[__] are always bullying people hey you
couldn't come and help us could you I'm
the Hufflepuff jeweling Club captain and
some of the students in my house could
really use some help with their
defensive spells well okay but it'll
have to be quick okay everyone har has
agreed to show us poo our Julian Club
junior Champion has bravely volunteered
to help help okay Harry off you
go oh here we go Pego
time oh that's so much easier and makes
so much more sense than whatever it was
in the last
game Could you teach us how to charge
spells too show us how it's done
Harry cast charge D if I like
this wait down and then up oh you hold
down and then like fling It
Forward oh that's kind of cool oh so
that's how he was doing the
[Music]
three thanks Harry if you fancy another
go just sign up for a jewel on the
notice board over
there oh no potterhead I did not see
this about how to get the last gas
badge no no let me feel free to post it
again I I must have missed that take the
shrinking solution okay yeah to Jenny
now hey Nick is jinny still waiting for
me at the Quidditch gate I believe so
wagle wagle Hur to meet lots of waggling
waggling wait is that her here we are at
your choos hi Jenny I've made that
shrinking solution for you thanks Harry
that's brilliant you wouldn't believe
all the things I had to do on my way
back to you but I'm here
now oh sorry what is up I've arranged to
go with Dean welcome in he's not stopped
moaning since I told him I couldn't go
and now I can yeah dean of course you
better go with him I'll go with her see
you later Harry yeah wonder why we
weren't doing proo yeah just just
learned it there what was that potion
you gave to Jenny you've not been making
more things from that potions book have
you you you don't even know who the Half
Blood Prince is let's go to Hogs me the
record scratch I know that caught me off
guard for a second I thought like did I
have something open in another
window it's just I'm starting to think
this Prince character was a bit
dodgy isn't that Katy
Bell it's nothing to do with
you oh that part was crazy man when that
happen it's that necklace it must be
cursed just that that visual that mental
image of her just like suspended in
midair Malo knew about that necklace it
was on display at borgan and bur dude
the game is moving so given the necklace
in the lady's toilet how could Draco
have put it in there good luck today Ron
I know you'll be brilliant I'm res after
today's match mlag could up my spot fine
juice you look Dreadful Ron is that why
you put something in his cup Luna what
you're talking
about come on Harry we've got a game to
win you could be expelled for that make
you ready to the quiddit pitch by the
way yeah potterhead I never did see uh
your comment about getting the last gas
badge
so yeah feel free to or hold on maybe I
could back up I'm feeling really lucky
today oh here it is if you almost let
the potions timer lapse completely and
then finish in the end you can
earn no way so you got to let it almost
be about to
expire
interesting move super quick through the
story so you can spend more time on fch
Quest yeah true well wait so like could
I could I just stop doing the main quest
right now and just like start exploring
because the way that the game is kind of
I mean I guess I could but the way the
game is set up it it feels like they
want you to go do this I at least want
to wait till I get incendio though I
need to make sure that I can open up
everything
[Music]
we heard face is not playing he's
injured he's the top scorer too how
lucky is
[Music]
that all
right so next time I do a potion I need
to basically get it to the end and then
just finish right
before the timer
expires what do you think potterhead
like like 10 seconds or less or like 5
Seconds like how close do you have to
let it get I
wonder all right Nick I I definitely do
not remember today let's start the qu
season with a wind we here I am talking
like least about the game the scavenger
Quest time shps in the
story
yeah that's like the the the games
really had difficulty with that didn't
[Music]
they oh yeah we need to make sure we use
all oh I just might as well grab that
while we're
here
Sprint for that Crest
[Music]
Harry yeah I don't know why like the
exploration feels much better to me in
this one than order the Phoenix Carol
I I'm liking it a lot
[Music]
more
and I fully admit it could a huge part
of that could be the simple fact that
this one just feels so much
better dashing k pass
friend wait I didn't delete your
message yucka I'm not sure what happened
there with your message it said I
deleted it maybe it was a uh maybe
automod guided or something we do keep
it family friendly I don't know if you
said
[Music]
something Tom welcome in brings back so
many memories yeah the music is great I
agree and welcome to the channel uh
Rasmus welcome in welcome in oh it did
it again it says this message was
deleted yua I'm sorry dude I'm not sure
what's going on it it might be an Auto
mod thing are you trying to post a link
or something if you're trying to post a
link I think those are uh those get get
blocked
[Music]
automatically all right now they've
given us a moving Target
here yeah it doesn't even show it to you
guys yeah it pops up on my screen I
think it was an automod thing gotcha L1
Tom I am playing on the
[Music]
PS3 and it looks like we got Wookie
cookie becoming a channel member Wookie
cookie welcome to house racking tour
thank you so
much oh man we missed
it thank you so much for the love and
support you are now officially part of
house Tren tour which means you can use
all of the emotes
all the Wizarding World themed emotes
that we
have come on excuse me excuse me excuse
me and
launch oh dude this one's this one's
going to be a challenge isn't
it this one's going to be a
challenge oh yucko was trolling gotcha
okay so it was it good job automod then
automod actually doing their uh doing
their
job
come on get up but yeah as uh whenever
you're a member you also get access to
uh we we do some special members only
videos actually just posted one was it
yesterday I think we just did one
yesterday or the day before there we go
nice so Wookie cookie make sure you
check those out we also do some members
only polls and Community posts from time
to
time so if you don't normally check the
Community page once you become a member
make sure you uh take a look at that
well well if it isn't poy Potter and
weasel King you're going to lose today
slithering are Supreme leave this to me
I'm feeling pretty confident what was
was y actually typing
that what and now for you Potter let's
see how well you play Quidditch after
you've been stupified
oh wait oh wait oh wait oh
goodness this man is aggressive
who are
you oh no oh dude oh my
[Applause]
goodness bro this this man is Out For
Blood this man is out for look at look
at Ron Ron just standing over there in
the background oh my goodness they
actually have destruction physics that's
Prett
cool what Pego was
out all right all right come on Harry
come on
Harry there we go there we bless this
guy I did too early see I got to back up
man like he's so
close oh we got him again come on let's
bring it back let's bring it
back come on just hit him once just hit
him once there we
[Music]
go got him sorry about that
Harry so yeah Ron thanks for
nothing let in that guy just go crazy on
me dude Voldemort needs to hire that guy
he wants to take out Harry
sheesh that man that man was uh Out For
Blood nice elen I love it I love it
Wingard him
leosa and the club just just Bonks them
right on the head all right this looks
like a repairo situation cuz we we
destroyed that actually in that fight
which is kind of cool but now let's see
can we repair it
it doesn't look like it's
repairing poo doesn't work when you're
knocked down
right
right okay Nick lead the way dude I
definitely do not remember the way
through the
caves okay so I think the little mini
Crest I definitely have gotten these
already so they just keep coming
back which I'm okay with that it's going
to help help help uh
make that not so tedious to get all of
those which how many do we have wasn't
it like 300 total or something we have
total
[Music]
already and you go to the wiing willow
to see if it's
real dude I don't know if you can go to
the wiing Willow and in this
[Music]
game oh come on Harry yes and we just
got another uh big crest for
that Wario said important tip when you
are told to join the Slytherin dueling
Club make sure you go out of your way to
do so it's the one and only optional
dueling spell in the game no way when
you when you can go to the Slytherin
dueling Club okay
gotcha good tip good tip
all right so where is an object there it
is just that perfectly placed
Boulder I tell you man these
Boulders they just they know how to get
in just the right
[Music]
spot all right we're getting better at
that
[Music]
too make you want to relive your
childhood did you play this one growing
up this is one that I never
played
yeah we definitely need to learn
incendio before I just start going crazy
[Music]
exploring oh yeah you go toward the
houry that's
right the Lord of the Rings
music I can hear it I I can definitely
hear it
make for the bridge of
[Music]
Kad
Lumas a well time depulso wait did we
learn
depulso
what I don't think we learned the
pulso is the pulso even in in this game
no it's not I guess that's what they
consider
Stupify match you guys this isn't the
final
battle oh it's the mini Crest spell okay
okay I mean I feel like we're we're
marching to
the Battle of Hogwarts
here it's like oh no it's just a
quiditch
match they're all listening watching
it's just a quidditch match dude those
quidditch players so noisy so rowdy oh
Sor wait so you actually I my team to
keep the noise down as I heard so bad
things about that one the captain to you
might as well use my shortcut too all
the team captains do my password is
boiled beetles thanks all right so we're
slowly knocking out the portraits too
boiled that's a trophy as well boil
boiled yes they like that with
[Music]
me I thought we were supposed to go to
quidditch
man why are we
back come on Nick oh H good luck today
let St could seon for the wi shall we
here I am walking away you better get to
the quid pitch oh he was just unlocking
the shortcut okay so we should just go
right back through it beetles beetles
beetles yeah that's the guy in order of
the Phoenix who's like they're
everywhere and now the music's done all
right I guess it's not such an epic
quidditch match
anymore hello Teresa welcome to the
Stream
all right so we already got the crest
that was there here we are let's go and
be Slytherin what's do it he's just
feeling lucky right time for our
pre-match warmup I've planned a few
exercises that should help us get
through so get your brooms and let's get
flying wait I thought this was the game
it's another practice
oh oh warm up before the match okay all
right all right all right all right all
right
Lorena welcome yeah the music was for
finding the shortcut I love it this epic
portrait requires some epic
music chasing through the ring you can
practice if you're in a real
[Applause]
match okay so you guys said if the
dummies pop up I actually need to hit
them which I did not know
that was so
small I mean it didn't seem to affect
anything negatively
wa oo they're getting a little bit more
oh I missed that
one I was about to say they're getting a
little bit more Challen in h
[Music]
St come on Captain you can do better
than
that hit the practice dummies to earn
extra time okay so we don't we don't
really need extra time
but I'll hit them this time as long as
you're hitting the Rings you you don't
need extra time I guess there's
one there's one there's
one like where even is the time is
invisible it's not showing us the
time try
harder
oh maybe it's the timing on the each
ring how glasses they're positioning
these literally like right with the
Rings
and then those are just on their
[Music]
own I guess on those long stretches like
that like if you didn't hit them it'd be
much harder to get through the ring in
time whoo whoa whoa whoa
whoo oh
[Music]
nice yeah I guess that's what it I guess
that's what it gives you more time for
the color between each ring
potterhead have a good one appreciate
you stopping
by V Outlaw welcome to the
stream yeah yeah yeah the timers the the
color
change
gotcha all right first quidd match thech
and chasing after it we got the
announcer
now Lee
Jordan
that like it
hurt got the now they got the epic music
going this this definitely feels more
qush than what we had legging up to
it almost got the
snch
Fantastic it's been so fascinating to
like see how they change
quidditch throughout the Potter games
like this one is very much on
Rails like really you have very limited
control of your
guy you just kind of have to make sure
he goes to the
[Music]
Rings great St it's definitely way
easier than what it what it used to be
great go there the one on uh philosopher
stone the PC version Oh My
Gosh trying to do that on the keyboard
[Applause]
hold on
Luna I got to win this quidditch match
then I'll let you
out wait
stop the snch is buring his
sights out of my
way
give it here Maloy I'll knock you off
your BR s has an
[Applause]
advantage amazing go yeah you can
definitely tell when I hit an object it
turns yellow a lot more and the match
mov
oh player in the match
today I mean visually it looks like
we're getting
close oh wait wait wait wait wait wait I
can't see the sun's so
bright griffindor Take the
[Applause]
Lead oh here we go who is that in front
of me by the way like what other
Gryffindor player would be up this high
this far away from
the he's near
s this is got to be it right this is got
to be it let's
go let's go you shouldn't have done it
Harry Felix Ficus is illegal in
organized
competitions I suppose I should have
just confounded mlagan and the trials
instead don't worry your secret safe
with me oh and Ron only thought I'd
given it to him it turns out he can make
his own luck
[Music]
oh is it Zachariah Smith in this game he
won't need me to take him to sl's
Christmas party and you'd better decide
who you're going with oh that's right
would graduated I know Harry I've seen
how you look at her Amion I'm sure Ron
oh don't worry about Ron he can make his
own life
shut up her
[Music]
minione yeah did Draco play in your
six I know he played let's see when did
Draco start on the team it was chamber
right portraits told me to I can't help
if I mind he's got on nickers in a Twist
what LA and I have well let's just say
it's chemical there's no stopping it
suppose you're going to slug on party
yeah I I better go I'm meeting Luna down
by the boat house Luna you could take
any girl in the castle and you're taking
Looney love good yeah one one o Have
Fun find Luna at the boat house and take
her to slug Horn's
party dude look I love the they change
the robes
too wait where is she
at have you
seen seen no heard yes I think I
overheard
her
hogwards wait is that what this is right
here Crest collector number
seven oh are yall going out
there have
fun Crest collector number
seven and there's another one right
there let's see do we have a separate
Boulder for
it no hold on Nick I'm not ready yet I'm
not ready I'm not ready let me just go
back and grab that
Boulder we'll use you again
now that we know how to do
this come on come on
Boulder come
on all right we'll drop it right there
and then kind of
reposition hi Luna no Luna I'm not ready
yet ni dress do you think I should wear
my radish earings as well M what's up
dude go with no no you look fine I'm
glad you came Professor slug hornn asked
me to set these Fireworks off to
announce his party but I'm not sure what
you're supposed to do with Okay good we
just need to cast incend yes incendio
finally okay cast incendio like this up
down up down up down
incendio that's pretty let's light the
others yeah dude I i' never played this
one before this is my first time ever
playing
this
I was telling the chat earlier I'm not
sure why I never played it like if I was
just too busy with other games at the
time or what but I played Order of the
Phoenix and that was the last one I
played until the Lego
games so I never played this one I never
played deathly Halls part one or deathly
Halls part
two oh my gosh where did that Boulder go
dude did it put it back up here oh it
did it brought it back over
here that's fine that's fine that's fine
we'll just go
[Music]
back
okay all right and
launch right
there nice okay so now we just have to
go around and set off all of
these
you have to lift it up
[Music]
first now what do we do with
it that's all okay maybe that's what you
were supposed
to yeah I was going to say maybe that's
what I was supposed to use
[Music]
Warrior so Ron Draco Flitwick Luna crab
boiled de show and Cormac so those were
all the movies all the uh the same
actors as the movies good call sh don't
last forever and your time all this be
destroyed in a battle
right there's a it's really nice but
it's magic so they can rebuild it very
easily all right we're ready to go to
the party Luna this
way
oh there's another one right there next
one
H dude why is this so fun setting off
all these
fireworks there's another one right
there
that's
pretty now we know incendio so we should
be able to unlock all the crests now we
should be able to grab any that we
need new area
unlocked managed the AAS have opened
this part of the castle now come on
let's get a slug horns
party
dude I'll be glad once we're done with
the the mini crests though oh that's
right we didn't know reparo
yet when we saw that for the first
time hey and that's
50 officially a third of the way
there
[Music]
yes sir
Dylan one step closer to that glorious
platinum
[Music]
trophy
lift and throw objects oh wait is there
another Crest out here that I
missed we already hit that Crest
so there is another
[Music]
one all right line it
up it opened the
door what okay that was funny I was not
expecting the party now maybe we need to
stand on this step right here to launch
it but now do I actually have to go out
there and retrieve
it man it's so dark even with lumos I
mean it barely it barely creates any
[Music]
light okay I don't think you can do the
bench right here can
you have you forgotten something you
checked an hour ago uh oh about the
order the
voices okay so let's carry it up to like
right
here then we'll
turn come on please
work get it right over
here
oh dude this one's going to be so
frustrating because we have to keep
opening this
door I think we do need
this I think we do need to go up
here oh come
on maybe if we stand like kind of
halfway
up boom let's go
finally all right Luna now we can
go see Luna is the type of person though
she would be totally cool with like a
detour like
that she would be totally fine with
[Music]
it
speaking of Luna my Luna wants back in
Surprise are you ready to go to
[Music]
the stay here Luna if you guys are new
here my dog is named Luna I have a West
Highland
Terrier okay I don't think we were
supposed to go in here were
[Music]
we lead the way
Luna not not
[Music]
you we all know she's a
cat o and a Crest another Crest dude I
love the easy ones like that just
sitting right there in your path
[Music]
all right that must
mean come on can we hit
that
[Music]
nice it's still just 25 I was wondering
if it went up at any point he had to
collect more than 25 I sleep Walky
that's why I wear shoes to bed
nice another one another easy one let's
[Music]
go the new shortcut oh is this a new
shortcut oh wait what is that up
there are you ready to go to the park no
Luna we got another Crest see we need it
we need
it all right so can I oh perfect we can
pick this
up and Miss terribly oh it puts it back
right
here that's actually really
nice what if I just put it right up
beside
it
wait hold on a second is that even where
it is or did it already
[Music]
fall wait is it there I think I see it
it did
fall come on over
here so as soon as it gets on the ground
it's like oh now we Guardian Leviosa
magically works it magically works now
when it's on the wall though no
sir nope nope nope nope
nope are you ready to go to the Parky
[Music]
now yeah Luna I think we're
ready until we find another Crest are
you ready to go to the at which point
we'll have to stop again all right this
probably going to be a cut scene for
part of it he my boy glad you came there
are so many people I want you to
meet Professor slug horn there's no one
else here course not and a good job too
how's it going dude ready that's where I
could do with a spot of help I'm sure
you and Miss uh uh love good here we'll
soon get the place in shape I was going
to rustle up a party punch for my guests
but time has not been willing could you
mix something for me
perhaps
oh of course stir the punch oh here we
go
stirring they're introducing stirring we
haven't had to do this up to this
[Music]
point stir the party punch until it
turns this
color
stir the party punch until it turns this
color there we
[Music]
go oh was there was there somebody else
warrio did I miss
it to try again N I think we're
good oh no of course all right maybe try
to get the trophy right here though okay
so oh my goodness where is it is it this
thing oh I I knew I did it too
much isn't that quite enough
smoke yeah it is Horus my bad dude my
bad okay now we need to Stir
It
oh come
on change color
you there we
go what is
that I I don't even know what that
is is it these the oranges why is it
showing a green color right there though
one two oh because we need it to change
to Green look Lively there no nodding
off we're going to lose this we're going
to lose this you are doing very well my
boy dude it is definitely getting harder
like what is
[Music]
that I don't even know if this is the
right one yeah just let it expire that's
all the time you
[Music]
have all right so we start with this
one we got off on the wrong foot last
time oh we almost did it again that one
it is VE a very narrow window right
there same thing for that one I almost
let it get
to see how dark it was the last one was
the green bottle which has a sprayer
okay good good good thank
you I was way wrong about that
one
all
right okay the
oranges
one
two
three much faster much faster all right
oh I see it now I see it
now okay until it turns
blue again super
quick
am I doing something wrong there we goes
finally are very well my boy what is
that lemons two
[Music]
lemons one okay that's definitely the
pumpkin
juice
stir again dude look how many
ingredients waiting for that purple
coloration right there we are good at
this aren't you strawberries now three
of them
one two and three almost there keep up
for good
[Music]
work
oh you are do very well my
boy dude we we got so much time oh no
steady on there har
boy I don't feel whenever I'm doing the
Fanning thing like I don't feel like
it's working at all okay wait we need
this one again
now
all right now I'm going to
wait I'm going to wait until it's at
about 20 seconds oh my gosh you guys
imagine if I don't get it though imagine
if I don't get
[Music]
it I'm going to start turning it slowly
because I don't
knowy I do not want to do this one all
over again we're trying to get a trophy
that you have to finish it at like the
last
second you know
what I'm going to get it at least close
keep those eyelids
open oh D up the good
work Wonderful a nectar from the gods a
taste of sunshine and happiness I knew
you were the man for the job my boy our
guests are here well here's a good
question morio so once you beat the game
stop there Potter I can you still do
potions message Professor D me to give
you oh there's a potion you see he's
traveling and W return until ter resumes
traveling where take your hands off me
you filthy squid no no Mr Hils what is
all this fuss about okay okay I was gate
crashing happy I'll escort him
out
that definitely could work
Wario Jackson yes we playing on
PS3 PS3 with
the hard copy of Half Blood prints what
were you doing all right follow Draco oh
this must be the sectum
simpra are they setting it
up slightly differently in the game get
your lesson Potter
10 points from Gryffindor for skulking
about try again oh I'm I'm supposed to
be
quiet
[Music]
whoops not supposed to let them see me
what were you doing there I don't have
to tell you
[Music]
anything where's my invisibility cloak
do you
dude I need my invisibility cloak oh go
go go go go around I am trying to help
you oh Luna you got to be kidding me you
just came back in just came back in
here you just want to steal my
glory they go in
here I'm guessing I'm
guessing oh I think I messed up I think
they're gone maybe I did hex that Katy
Bell girl maybe I didn't what's it to
you I swore to protect you I made the
unbreakable vow I don't need protection
I was chosen this is my
moment this is my moment bloody hell you
don't think snake was just pretending no
he even said he'd taken an unbreakable
oath the unbreakable vow yeah what what
happens if you break an unbreakable
vow you
die oh wait is this the burrow attack oh
it totally is one of the most bizarre
unnecessary sequences in the movie I
don't sleep these days so I wash my hair
silly
right happy Christmas
Harry Bella shrinks
I love how he knew before he actually
saw
her hello oh no it's playable it's not
just a cut
scene oh
jeez
oh go Harry go
[Music]
crazy
Oh I thought I blocked it in
time nice go go go go
[Applause]
go yikes oh she's catching up come on
get up get up get up get up get
up
[Applause]
there we
[Music]
go
what how is she not
[Music]
down just trying to do foro
but
there we
go
incendio but blood trest to the dark
lord don't you see she wants you to
chase her she killed
Sirius dude the vo on that was
so jiny just fell off I'm okay
where are you keep running I'll find you
come to play
Harry oh no not
[Applause]
again
super
yikes get up get up get up get up get up
get up get up get up get
up
there we
go Harry come on dude you got to be more
accurate than
that no I knew that was happening going
to
happen anti
Bellatrix what what is that
[Music]
dialogue okay the destruction around you
that's pretty cool
actually no I wanted Pego not not the
charge not the
charge I going to say I might actually
lose this one if we don't start okay
let's charge one up
[Music]
now what you dodged all those no
way oh we both hit it come on get up get
up get
[Music]
up oh that was nice
foro all right that should do it that
should do it that should do
it get close when
you spam Stupify oh after you hit her
with expelling armis I
see no hurry it's a trap get away from
her what another
[Music]
fighty
oh
nice bro finer has got to work on his
dueling
man he's not he's not as talented as
spell
tricks dude he's gotting hit by every
spelling
arm oh come on
there we
go are you all right yes thank you Harry
hey Michael what's up dude welcome in so
many members from this game not all
great I'm liking it better than order
the Phoenix so far yeah he you could
definitely tell that right there
military man thanks for you know jinny
if You' not got there I could have had a
werewolf for a sister uh yeah no
problem dad said he checked borgan and
Burks he said mfo was looking at a
Vanishing cabinet a Vanishing cab what
would he want with one of those don't
know the dad said it was still there in
the
shop The Vanishing
CET he's up to something I just don't
know what it
is up to something hi Harry Ron Harry I
think Professor slug horn is having
another party for invited guests slug
Club maybe slug horn can make you and
clag and king and queen slug see you
Harry amay have you seen Malfoy doing
anything suspicious oh really Harry are
you still worried about draer Ron told
me his dad found out Malfoy was was
looking at a Vanishing cabinet in borgan
and burgs but there's no way he could
sneak a Vanishing cabinet into the
castle the auras are searching everyone
who comes in they're even checking the
Outpost then you tell me how he
disappears off the Marauders map I'll
show you I solemnly swear that I am up
to no
[Music]
good little scene with
a show a mway disappearing managed he's
there in the seventh floor Corridor so
he's not not disappeared then has he but
sometimes he does vanish completely I'm
going to find out what he's up to I'm
going to the seventh floor what's that I
here sounds like a scoop to me hot news
goes cold fast you better use my
shortcut just say happy headlines do you
really think you'll find anything Harry
yes I'll prove he's up to
something investigate what Draco is up
to in the sth floor
corridor
we can repair
this can we just talk about how op the
Marauders map really is if you think
about
it I
mean it shows the name the identity of
people talk about an invasion of uh
privacy just to see exactly where you
are inside Castle you sell more
newspapers than free gifts you
do oh you just went to Wizarding World
Jackson that's awesome man I'm I'm going
to try to go most likely this
year it's been so long since I went down
there to the one in
Orlando I haven't even been since they
added all
the Diagon Alle stuff which I've heard
is even better okay can we get yeah
let's try to get that Crest over
here
no gather the mini ones Wii leosa all
right then let's aim
this and
miss all right right here come
on
what there it
is all right Nick hello Nick uh oh wait
they said seventh floor didn't Draco
Maloy anywh not today know but I have
seen him many times in the seventh floor
like students made it the map I know
right try there two students or students
full of mischief four students is full
of
[Music]
mischief oh another Crest hold on
Nick hold on one moment Wingardium
Leviosa
ah I got to back up a little
bit like if they would just have given
you a free aim ability like whenever I
do this if I hold R2 and then it let me
fire it it would have been so much
better wait where did it
go where dides it
go oh no no did we just glitch
it oh it went
through oh
man yikes and we just unlocked Crest
collector number
eight the MPC was AP poed crab or [__]
what like somebody that I just walked
by this
person
wheni leosa oh no didn't mean to do
that in fact wait what is
[Music]
that why can I not grab
you thank you vaugh it might have just
been was it that one I just grabbed
right there
hey beill have a good one thank you for
hanging
[Music]
out in the book she dropped things and
sneezed to give Draco the signal if
somebody is
outside oh that's
crazy that is
crazy right there
there that's
cool the little details man we
arrived Hey Ron have you seen
Malfoy when just now he's always hanging
around on this Corridor and I just found
this it looks like instructions for a
potion it's probably homework and since
when has Maloy put effort into his
homework you don't even know it's his
I'm going to ask her what this potion is
I bet that will give us a clue to what
Malfoy is up to you're in luck she's
swatting in potions now careful she's
still in a right mood so you won't come
with me then I think I'd rather face
that troll we saw in our first year see
you
later he said
nah
nah not interested all right find her
Mindy in the potions
[Music]
classroom hi Nick have you seen her
anywhere hold on Nick before we do this
before we do this the potions hey Marky
boy welcome
in thank you for
subscribing I'm not sure why the alerts
have they they've been about I don't
know working what what would you guys
say 60% of the time or so
today then the other times they're just
like
nah nah not going to work this time
but Marky boy appreciate you stopping by
and hanging
out all right we need an object to throw
here right here wardi
[Music]
leosa come
on you heading out Jackson hey thanks
for being here have a good one
whoa whoa whoa camera camera
camera okay at least once they fall you
can do that to bring them
over catch Snippets of conversation from
NPC's mentioning moments from the books
hey that's pretty
[Music]
cool oh wait was that a repair
raro that's what it is okay but then
what wardian
Leviosa wait a second man what is
this is it like some
scale do we not fully repair it okay
it's
it's hm and then it breaks
again it's a potion scale am I supposed
to use it for something I
think oh there's another Crest hanging
somewhere Guardian
leosa I see something what
is oh that's the little uh flying
[Music]
bird it's just what the girl dropped
okay okay all right well then how do I
interact with the the banners
[Music]
here so I don't have
like in the last game it was like I
think you could do wingardium on some of
them you're supposed to run under them
and then jump at the right time wait
jump
how do you
[Music]
jump oh it's a prompt that
appears oh like this one I see I
[Music]
see
well no not that
one the one that was hanging from the
ceiling hanging from the ceiling in the
other
Corridor
okay I mean that one's hanging from the
ceiling
[Music]
but oh you think oh is this the one
though is this the
one it's like a little bit of a delay
with the stream so I
can't what oh my
gosh dude how would anybody ever find
that what the heck man
the game hasn't even told me you can do
that oh and I bet you have to do
itard we didn't get it though we we got
I think we got like the first one and
then we messed up come on Harry turn
this
way oh I didn't hit
it there should have been an onscreen
prompt yeah I didn't I didn't see
anything okay we got it turn around turn
around turn
around oh come
[Music]
on and then it goes back up doesn't it
if you don't hit it in time dude this is
crazy oh I missed that
one come on what
why is it so
hard yeah so there's
one that's the first one then two three
so okay I've got to get three in a
row yeah Arvin that's what I was
thinking you had to do but for some
reason it's
proving easier said than
done like why is that
am I too early or am I too
[Music]
late no no no no come on Harry
no you just know from LP's in reviews oh
yeah I I like I can't imagine how you
would ever find this especially if there
there's no no prompt for
[Music]
it straight down the middle okay all
right here we go
let's Nick's like dude what are what are
you what are you doing
man
yes oh my
gosh
bro I should have saved that that one
for
last shees good call Wario on
remembering
that trying to hit it with the wand yeah
yeah I can I could see that a bit
now wow yeah I would have never found
that I would have never found
that if I wasn't streaming
this I really must pay vet a
visit oh the fat lady talking about
Violet I know secrets that are actually
hidden it's kind of
cool
libres liberate you speak the password
so may
pass pass
word all right I I've already forgot
what we were doing I think we're trying
to find
Hermione in
Potions you're here help
now hello herione do you recognize this
potion I'm surprised you you don't
recognize it seeing as your top in
potions it's obvious what this is't
happy about that what is it why ask me
you should ask the Half Blood Prince all
right I will well I can make the potion
and find out
anyway all right potion
time shredded boomslang skin take one
booms slang skin dry until dry then
Shred okay heat it up dude it's like
they've introduced so many mechanics Now
by this
point oh no Luna you just came back in
you can
wait all right seven of these
guys
one
got it stewed lacewing
flies o that one was close to
uh smoking on
[Music]
me I mean it's already
so now stir again till it's green
oh come
on FL we Luna
[Music]
no heat it now heat it till it's
orange
boom right
there all right the red
one two more of these
guys stir until it's
gray come on
come
on oh my goodness that one take
[Music]
forever back again now we hary and a
splendid poly juu potion you're making
but I do hope you're not intending to
take it it is a restricted potion you're
sure it's Pol
sir gray and sludgy finish all
characteristic but then you should know
myad you made it I was just
experimenting thanks sir poly juice
potion you use that if you want to look
like someone else I wonder what Malfoy
would want with that Voldemort isn't
going to trust Malfoy with a mission you
haven't got a scrap of evidence have you
no not yet but I'll get
something
transition Dumbledore wants you to go to
his office for another lesson Harry when
you see Dumbledore don't say anything
about Malfoy he's up to something he's
sneaking around and he's even ditched
crab and goil yes I admit that is out of
character but you don't have evidence
that he's doing anything if he's not
then why is he sneaking around the
seventh floor and the seventh floor
that's it he's using the room of
requirement that's why he keeps
disappearing off the Marauder's Map well
if he is using the room he won't be able
to see what he's doing in there that's
why we used it for da meetings
concentrate on your lesson with
Dumbledore he's waiting for you in his
office meet Dumbledore in his office man
they really do like the way it just it
really does move you along the
story all right guys you are totally
right Michael we have been playing for a
while I think that's going to be a good
stopping point I think that is going to
be the a good point to
stop but we will definitely do this
again I want to play through this whole
game I want to get the platinum trophy
most likely I'm thinking Tuesday might
be the stream day going forward but I'll
always make sure to put it up with you
know at least like 12 hours preferably
preferably more notice so on Youtube
it'll always show you a exactly when the
stream is has been set and going to go
live but this is I am I I got to say man
I'm enjoying this way more than I did
order the Phoenix now another part of it
could be because I'm also live streaming
it with you guys which uh definitely
makes things oh look at that 62 out of
we got 62 crests some are still
inaccessible until you have the right
spell I think we have all of them now
practice your dueling skills at the
dueling
Club very cool man
very very
cool all right guys thank you all for
being here hope you all have a wonderful
rest of your Friday thank you guys for
all the all the gifted
memberships that we had earlier the
likes the super
chats the uh people becoming members
once
again hope you guys had fun and enjoyed
the stream today it's uh it's been it
has definitely been too long Jenny I
agree has been too
long
Ryan thank you for the lovely stream
been hanging
out thank you for the lovely stream been
great hanging out with you all much much
love to you all hey same to you ran
thank you for being here Warrior do not
worry about it man just you guys being
here and hanging out it really does mean
a lot I appreciate
it yep Anna you have a good one too have
a good
one but man this was fun if you guys
anybody who watches it in the replay
Squad don't forget the lion Emoji in the
comments
throw that line Emoji in the comments
let us know you made it this far oh
actually you know what now if they made
it all the way to the end we should add
a different one give us give us the
snake Emoji if you made it to the very
end snake Emoji if you made it all the
way here to the very end of the video I
saw you guys saying that uh expecto go
apparently post posted a video recently
you guys could head over there and check
out his video If you haven't given a
thumbs up here on this one make sure you
do but that's going to be it for me stay
warm guys stay warm stay safe have a
great week weekend as always thank you
all so much for watching and I will talk
to you again
soon